[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys guys it's wednesday
time for the episode yeah
you know cursed objects
yeah well this was like some leftover
[ __ ] from the urban legends show okay
cause like i said well not all of it is
obviously just mostly the paintings
because remember when we did the urban
legend show last week and i was like oh
i had like all these kind of cool
paintings i want to talk about i didn't
get to it
and then i was like well maybe i should
just do like a whole cursed objects show
like including paintings and some other
[ __ ]
so i put it in the poll and it won now
i shortened it up because prior to this
i had like a whole bunch more [ __ ]
because you know i can't self-edit
and there was like a bunch of [ __ ] that
i wanted to put in here that i thought
was interesting but well you might have
to open that because it's closed because
she's just kind of like she understands
that it goes through there but you know
okay
um
but yeah uh so
what was i even saying i lost my train
of thought because pookie was like why
is this why is this jordan
we're just trying to get in the groove
here
yeah
uh dj maniac says i have an arleigh irmi
doll that swears when you push a button
on his back
yeah where did you get that do you
seriously have that yeah they made all
kinds of weird that's my cursed object
i love it i mean so there's like a bunch
of stuff i wanted to cover but you know
obviously we didn't have time to but i
just like picked some [ __ ] that i
thought was cool so it was just kind of
like mommy's curse hope diamond the
paintings i was gonna do screaming
skulls but there's too many of those and
they pretty much all do the same thing
so you know so i took most of those out
but uh i don't know it should be fun and
like i said if it's it's another one
where if we don't get to everything it's
not a big disaster
but i did go through and like take out a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah so i am just saying
that
yeah
all right
let's see why isn't tom wearing his
cursed skull ring oh i forgot it it's
over in there it's in the other room i
just you haven't worn that for a while
actually i don't know where it's it's
actually a little bit too big
yeah it wants to fall off um
i have a ring like that that somebody
gave me that's like [ __ ] giant it's
like it's a little bit too big like
man's ring yeah like how fat do you
think my fingers are
yeah
but uh esther's in there hoping that you
publicly humiliate me again oh boy yeah
people are like what i missed that
i understand something man
me and jenny fight sometimes especially
when we're drunk
she [ __ ] really [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
well because well you because you kind
of like pick on me like a lot of the
time so it's like that's kind of like
i'm trying to get you back
a lot of it has to do with [ __ ]
strange [ __ ] that she's on that has a
lot to do with it [ __ ] she'll go into
she starts [ __ ] manning up on me it's
like getting aggressive well you were
the one that wanted me to take that [ __ ]
though
[Laughter]
replacement therapy works but [ __ ] on
injection day
[ __ ] a woman he's gonna get [ __ ]
me you know messing my voice up with
it's messing my voice up well that's why
i took you off of i took you off don't
don't you know just let it all reset it
didn't make it just they'll do that a
little bit but it's temporary
um just you just can't run that for for
a long time because i've noticed that
like sometimes when i'm talking like my
voice keeps dropping out and it's
getting like kind of it'll go back
it'll go back okay
and you said you thought because you
heard me in here talking like recordings
yeah i was like her voice getting a
little deep it's time for her
yeah hey what's up yeah
it wasn't it wasn't test she's on she's
she's on regular uh uh hrt which is you
know 20 milligrams a week that's
standard for post-menopausal women they
can run that forever it was other [ __ ]
you can't you can't really be on that
longer than a couple months
and
it works it's just it's got to come off
and on and off and on and you can't live
on that
but it's
and i had been on it longer than you
realized i think it was was the deal
yeah well it was more because i don't
know i don't keep track of the [ __ ] he
just comes in and like [ __ ] well it
was two compounds back to back oh okay
all right
uh you know which you know some of the
some of this [ __ ] you know it's all
legal stuff it's stuff that you can get
here in florida
uh if you're on if you're if you if you
if you're part of an hrt clinic they'll
prescribe it to you
um
female doses are [ __ ] tiny compared
to men's they're one-tenth because it
just doesn't take it's very cheap to
model woman out on it
we're a cheap date yeah they're very
cheap
it's just um
the first one was alexandra alone and
that you know which is little pills you
know some people know that xanavar
that's that's a girl steroid
but
she's on that for a couple months and
then [ __ ] you can do real small
doses of winstrol
um and
i realized that you know that was about
four months
back to back
the doses are tiny but they're different
compounds it's fine
it's just uh
after about four months it's time time
to
come off you let all your [ __ ]
receptors [ __ ] clear out and you're
and then uh your receptors are like
where is that [ __ ] and they'll start
growing more of them
so three or four months later when you
cycle back on it's a better response
because the body has been looking for
that
what she was on is
very basic for post-menopausal hrt
the end result usually is to slim
someone down
give them a more youthful appearance but
you can't live on that it's
cycle everybody knows about it they've
been doing it since the 50s
dj maniac says that uh that he sent you
a video of his early army doll in action
so we might have to see that yeah i
might i might need that for for
valentine's day or something
yeah because i could just have them like
swear at everybody yeah but i'm real
open about what i do you guys know i've
been on hrt i told the [ __ ] audience
when i went on it you know over how long
has that been now two years
two years i have no idea and um time
means nothing if you're a man in your
40s or 50s and you're not on hrt you're
just dumb
it is life extension you'll be a lot
better you'll feel a lot better
um
you'll uh it saves you a lot of risk in
terms of like heart disease and
[ __ ] from over being overweight you
know to fight obesity
and just make you feel a lot better just
look at jack lalanne and all the greats
from the past guys that didn't abuse
[ __ ] lived a long time you could live
into your 70s or 80s and [ __ ] look
like have a body like you're in your 30s
you'd be like 75.
i got and i got videos to prove chinese
there's a chinese dude i'm competing
with i'm not competing for stallone or
[ __ ] arnold schwarzeneggers and those
[ __ ] those dudes were burned out by the
time they were 50. i'm looking at these
chinese dudes they're like 75 that went
on hrt when they were 40
those dudes [ __ ] they're just they're
just they didn't change they look
exactly the same just a little bit of
age in the face
but they're built better than any
[ __ ] 30 year old that that's and it's
reasonable they're not huge they're just
you've got a little fitness model dudes
and that's that's that's really what you
want to be
you just want to be real fit real
healthy real happy live a long time
zach says my cursed object is the 20k
acre in hawaii that the goddess pele ate
when kilauea erupted in 2018.
this was actually like a really fun
topic like i said there's so much
of it out there i kind of wanted to st
because
there's a lot of overlap between
sort of like cursed objects haunted
objects it's kind of like we did a show
[ __ ] man it was like it was years ago
now but i think we did a show that was
like
four
horror movies that were based on like
allegedly real incidents
and i think we talked on that show i
think we talked about the dybbuk box you
remember that like that was on one of
the uh it was on a haunting or
paranormal witness or something and that
was kind of like one of those things
that
uh you know somebody bought it on ebay
or whatever and like when you open it
like demons are supposed to come out or
whatever and they made a movie about it
so we talked about that
on
that show so i'm not gonna repeat that
and like i said i'm not going to talk
about
annabelle or robert the doll i do have a
couple other curse dolls in there that i
haven't talked about before but we've
talked about those on other shows so i'm
going to skip those but
i don't know so because there's kind of
a thing too where it's just kind of like
well there's this object but then
there's just like a haunting surrounding
it i kind of wanted to
have it more of a thing where if the
actual object
um
whoever owns it or you know interacts
with it like bad [ __ ] happens to them
like that's more like a classic curse
but you know there's a lot of wiggle
room there and i did want to do some
cursed phone numbers because i thought
that was kind of interesting too that
was another thing that kind of came up
during my research like i said i had
screaming skulls in here but
i didn't uh
i had to take them out because it was
just too much stuff
so i don't know but i think i got like a
good combo
of uh you know of stuff so i think it'll
be fun
i don't uh you know
i don't have any cursed objects
he thinks justin's he-man doll [ __ ]
cursed him back in 87.
people don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about how so
i don't know what he's talking about
let's hear the story we grew up with a
dude named steve rouse and his little
brother was justin the [ __ ] was
crazy all right he was funny as [ __ ] a
little kid
he'd be down in the basement [ __ ] he
had [ __ ] he-man dolls he's talking to
a little chucky cheese mouse calling him
grandpa and [ __ ] oh yeah that's right
i remember that
sorry crazy looking he-man toys
i don't remember i don't remember how
grandpa's interacting with the he-man
toys but he must have been down there
must have saw it he had that [ __ ]
he-man and that green
tiger he had all that i remember it
but just i mean
but we don't know like how i don't know
how this toy actually cursed him we need
to hear the story he's not saying we
need to hear the story i don't know i
don't even see that that comment which
is making me nervous scroll down
uh i am scrolled down
i i can you guys selected on all
comments or just top comments well it
just it goes to like top well okay yeah
there you go all right maybe there you
go
there we go i'm pretty sure justin t-man
doll put a curse on me it's still
[Laughter]
oh it's still causing problems with yeah
okay so is that is that what's causing
that problem
that's his e-d
causing problems with your e-d
i don't know
get on test man you'll rock a [ __ ]
diamond cutter
i don't know if that's such a good thing
though
vaginas all over the world just clinched
when you said that
diamond cutter no thank you
look man
stop getting me to act it up
why but you gotta get me to act that's
the whole fun that's the whole fun
is is you trying to get me to act up and
[ __ ]
well yeah that's why people watch the
show
they're waiting for us to start a fight
well it might happen we haven't we
haven't drunk all that much yes but
yeah that's right
it's gonna be all right it's gonna be a
good show yeah i know like i said
there's like a bunch of like fun stories
but like i said it's you know it's just
like fun go ahead hit that like button
people help us out with the show i'm
sitting here just trying to [ __ ]
get some free likes and get some send me
some money yeah it sounds shameless i
got my [ __ ] i got my damn mexican shirt
on made in mexico you were hecho in
mexico yeah yeah
mexico
high quality shirt that is a very nice
yeah bee's nest no
bees nest [ __ ] heart murder hornets
god gave me this yeah we still call them
bees nuts yeah got that on the mexican
border got that from boba fett
camp guy said i once was at a college
that had a very large mirror in the
basement of the performance theater they
said someone hung themselves in front of
the mirror and it was haunted yeah
there's a lot of i didn't i was gonna do
haunted mirrors too but then when i was
reading about it about those because
there's more than one
but that would kind of like laid on the
other end of that line where it seemed
like the mirrors
were just like haunted mirrors in the
sense that you look in it and like see
creepy [ __ ]
i kind of wanted more objects that were
like if you owned them like bad [ __ ]
would happen to you you know what i mean
i know that's like a weird distinction
but so i kind of felt like the haunted
mirror the cursed mirror ones were more
like haunted mirror rather than cursed
mirror you know what i think i don't
know maybe it's just i was trying to
narrow [ __ ] down is is basically what i
was trying to do
but and some of the [ __ ] that i came up
with you know obviously doesn't do that
either
you're just going to keep you can spin
around everything yeah no i'm just
trying to get in a good place like i'm
on a talk show yeah there you go yeah
i'll hit you what i'm doing i'm mike
douglas i got to be in a certain place
and i got to be there well no i just
i just wondered i wondered if you were
like uncomfortable and needed like some
other like because i got this [ __ ]
sitting right here
i'm looking out for your welfare though
[Laughter]
oh you love it
[Laughter]
trying to see what else is going on
you'll love it all right how's the uh
people are still coming in where's tayla
taylor's not in i don't know sandra
hasn't been in here in a long time i
don't know something must have happened
to her
no she commented on
um
[Music]
one of the kitty videos that i put up
yesterday so she's still alive yeah
she's just uh
not making the live shows
well it happens because like i said
especially if you're like in another
part of the world then yeah if it's like
[ __ ] two in the morning i understand
that people can't
we've talked about
changing the times up or like doing like
surprise ones or not doing them at the
same time but i don't know it's like i'm
kind of of two minds about that because
i get what you're saying that like maybe
if we do them at a different time
yeah then you're getting people that
never get to see you live which that's
cool but then like i kind of like having
at least like a rough time of doing them
so i can kind of like work around other
[ __ ] i have to do yeah but
i don't know it's you know doing one
real late in the evening you know three
o'clock in the morning is when we ought
to start
something like that
you think nobody wants to see me at
three o'clock in the morning it wouldn't
be three o'clock in the morning
oh i thought you meant three o'clock in
the morning like here yeah three o'clock
in the morning here but the people that
would be watching they wouldn't be it
wouldn't be three o'clock in the morning
for them no i meant nobody wants to see
what i look like at three o'clock in the
morning that's what i meant i don't want
to have to get up at three o'clock in
the morning
and [ __ ] no we do it like [ __ ] uh
coming back in the club
but then we'll like then like all my
[ __ ] i'll be all in together i'll be
all greasy and drunk
and i'm just like i wanna i want an egg
sandwich why
you know what i mean it'll be like that
it wouldn't be pretty is what i'm saying
yeah i mean if we could like probably
i don't know we could like not drink
that much and then come home i don't
know because a lot of times when we come
home it's kind of a long drive now and
it's i'm always like really tired
you know so it would be kind of like a
bummer i don't know we'll have to like
work something out at some point
yeah zach said uh legit that hawaiian
property was weird our electronics
always died see i thought you were
kidding are you serious our electronics
always died me and mom were always
fighting and in a bad mood we had to
sage it it was like the opposite of a
prayer wheel
oh my god all right uh granthurst is
asking you a question what do you say
question for tom the 101st airborne is
being sent to the baltics for the big
showdown with putin what will they be
doing oh man [ __ ] those dudes
well okay the hundred first thing to do
[ __ ]
the 101st as it's
as it's set up now
and i got people that still [ __ ] know
what the hell's going on
101st isn't really [ __ ] battle ready
all right it's there just for a show
there isn't going to be a war
this is all fake
if you look at what russia is doing it's
not doing anything unusual it's not
doing anything that hasn't been done in
the past 15 years
it's just that they need this or our
side you know the globalist side needs
this as a distraction to all these other
problems
just to get everything else out of the
damn news it's fake nothing will happen
we're not [ __ ] battle ready
we get our asses handed to us [ __ ]
against russia couldn't even handle
afghanistan a bunch of [ __ ] primitive
[ __ ] backward people with no money
russia the russian elites [ __ ] troops
are [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] bad asses you know i
mean these are these are white people
with degrees but they're from the hood
and they [ __ ] love being in the army
and they'll do things that [ __ ] our
chain of command would never do
the problem with the us army in our
military starts at the [ __ ] general
officer
level our generals are just [ __ ] they're
political generals they're not even
military men they shouldn't even be in
there
and then the officer corps is just
[ __ ] up that's just political and
none of that shit's battle ready
and i don't know who they're recruiting
they're [ __ ] as far as i know
recruitment's just [ __ ] non-existent
right now that's why they want robots to
replace everything just
the 101st airborne division that was my
old unit the 82nd those are obsolete
conventional
armies they're they're they're they're
not effective
they're expensive they they lose
that type of warfare is went out
really in the 80s you know that shit's
gone i mean that's the equivalent of
putting on a white wig and a [ __ ]
three-quarter hat and lining up and
shooting at each other with [ __ ]
muzzle loading rifles that's what you're
dealing with there everything is
mercenaries terrorists political action
groups propaganda it's all fifth
generational [ __ ]
but they're gonna go down there and
they're gonna do nothing and just
[ __ ] scare people and try to use that
as a justification for their
incompetency and
then they'll [ __ ] do something like
pull the power on us and say well the
russians did it it's gonna be something
like that
it's it i don't believe a word they say
i'm i'm done with the empire i'm like
[ __ ] solo how solo now i'm done with
the empire
camp guy says i have to get up about
every two or three hours every night to
either pee or let the little dogs out
yeah
i mean yeah i mean i i usually wake up
every three or four hours and a lot of
times i'll wake up between three and
four and i can't go back to sleep so
it's either because i have to go to the
bathroom or
because pookie jumps on my chest yeah
because she likes to run up that cat
wakes us up
religiously hey are you guys awake guys
up yet every four hours
i'll look over like i'll wake up and go
what the [ __ ] was that and look over and
roll over and see her and she's on her
side and standing on her shoulder it's
[ __ ] pokey
and he's looking at her and then he'll
look at me she'll look at me are you
guys up yet and i'm looking at the
[ __ ] clock
it's like 4 30 in the morning
i'm like pokey get down
and she's like are you guys gonna wake
up i'm just [ __ ] crazy it's like a
little kid
she is yeah i can't but you can't be mad
at her like this no because it's so
funny
it is it is very funny and it's like
even though it wakes me up i'm just kind
of like uh whatever yeah and honestly
like the last couple nights it's been
kind of chilly
so she's actually been pretty good she
kind of climbs up but then she kind of
settles down and she slept like between
my feet
like for almost seven hours which is a
big deal for her she didn't really move
all that much
terry says i like your necklace jenny
thank you very much
uh
yeah a camp guy says if i don't get up
right away my smallest poodle will just
go pee in the corner of the room on the
hardwood floor
pookie usually just like she doesn't
like wake us up for any reason she just
wakes us up i guess because she's bored
or she's like checking on us
sometimes it's because she's out of
treats
and then she is kind of more insistent
because she's like hey my shit's empty
but other than that it's like not she's
just like hanging out or checking on us
i guess
um all right so
do we have anything else we need to
discuss before we get into the stories
or
yes no
no just uh
graham the only reason why that shit's
any good is we have okay air force
the rest of the armed forces is very
very out of date
it's just
it's ceremonial
it's something from another era
but i'm done with that [ __ ]
i'm glad i'm not in there right now i
would never serve the [ __ ] current
channing i wouldn't serve i wouldn't
serve in the current [ __ ] empire
going back [ __ ] 10 years it just got
worse and worse and worse you know
it doesn't serve the it doesn't serve
the american people
not at all it serves the one percent and
they're not american
that's it that's all i want to say about
it
all right so are you ready to talk about
some [ __ ] cases all right you sure
yep
okay
yep so we're gonna do a couple mummy
curses now we're gonna do king tut's
thing because you know that's kind of a
famous one i don't think we've ever
talked about that
but one thing that i didn't realize
until i started uh researching this show
was that you know that other mommy that
they found uh otsi
otsi
ootsie oopsie that's when they found up
on top of the iceman yeah yeah i [ __ ]
saw whole programs of him know all about
the dude he even saw his little bow in
his arrow and his little quiver of
arrows and his little bow and arrow yeah
it is little he's a little dude i think
he was like five one
yeah i can't remember him
yeah
but uh but yeah there is also a curse
associated with him
which i did not know
but now
but now i do know and now you guys are
gonna know okay so uh all right so
little dude little ice man
uh first found in 1991 yeah up in the
mountains in northern italy yeah
uh so yeah he died during the late
neolithic period copper age as they
called it back in the old school old
school honky motherland i mean original
hockey
he's the o-h
that's right
that's right
oh my god there's another t-shirt
tom ross original original hockey
i
that was the original ones they were
even smaller
even smaller
well i mean you can't he's living up in
the snowy ass mountains and it was
uh they think he died what like more
than five thousand years ago yeah i have
five thousand three hundred years yeah i
don't think it's not anywhere though i
don't think he's like no i think he's
maybe just driven up here yeah like
because yeah they do think that he died
like in an attack
he had a lot of wounds on him that meant
that he was fighting with somebody yeah
and he ran up there
to safety and he died making another bow
yeah that's right yeah he was up there
yeah he was trying to make another one
to come back down something he got
driven off
yeah probably poor poor bastard yeah but
he might have been a bad guy
that's true he might have been raiding
somebody's damn
well i like to give dead people the
benefit of the doubt especially if
they're more than 5 000 years old i
don't know
he might have been a really nice person
he was up there by himself with a bunch
of wounds on it i don't think he was
though because i think that later on
like in the mid 2000s i think they found
like some other
um signs of somebody else yeah signs of
somebody else so he was there with a
party so yeah and he got they left him
behind i guess so because they're like
we're not we're not dragging it was
probably in a war party
i think it was something like that but
yeah they didn't actually find that out
until later they thought he was by
himself for a really long time
but uh yeah so like i said they found
him in 1991 very very famous
uh mummy that they found up there
uh but what more like a piece of beef
jerky well yeah like freeze-dried but i
mean mummy sounds a lot more better
better than jerky yeah a piece of beef
jerky
man jerky
so you wanna make a big
[Laughter]
it's all these power tops [ __ ]
jerking on each other with their little
[ __ ] cop hats on i got one where is
one yeah where's your where's your
[ __ ] i'll get it i'll get honestly
i would be shocked if there wasn't a gay
porn flick called man jerky manager
there has to be
i'm [ __ ] the story of this
what else is new
[Laughter]
he's gonna go get his [ __ ] hat i
was gonna tell wait till he comes back
because um i just recorded
a review
for
the gaspar noe film
uh
what the [ __ ] is it called irreversible
from 2002
and i have to tell tom but there's a gay
club in that that's in france and called
the rectum which i thought was very
funny
but
you know what i mean
i love names of gay bars
well no i was telling it's like i did a
i recorded a review of the very uh the
infamous uh gaspar noe film irreversible
which came out in 2002. and in that film
it's french and there's a gay club in
there that's called the rectum
in english that's it's called the rectum
so uh so i thought that was kind of
funny that's a [ __ ] up movie by the
way if you haven't seen it but um
yeah it wasn't a pleasant experience
it's a great movie but it was not not
pleasant to watch
because there's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happening than that but uh so yeah
where was that i kind of fixed the hat i
don't even remember cool um uh yeah so
oh we got distracted by man jerky i
remember yeah so he's a mommy i mean you
know just that sounds classier than man
jerky
um
sorry i was just thinking of that
[ __ ] uh was that commercial that they
used to have like this back in the 90s
for um
oh snap into a slim jim what [ __ ]
wrestler was that
what wrestler was that stood up into his
living room
all right no what was it um [ __ ] i just
i feel like i knew that i know that and
i can't think of it right i wasn't real
big i don't know why i just thought so
so from now on we're gonna call uh
ootsie the iceman we're gonna call him
slim jim
[Laughter]
somebody in the comments would know who
that was yeah i can't i'll i'll probably
remember it like five minutes from now
uh yeah so uh again like a bunch of
people apparently that had to do with
finding
uh the mummy
died mysteriously randy savage thank you
yeah yeah that's your man yeah macho man
yeah i knew he had like he was something
something name i knew there was
something like that yeah that's right uh
dress it up like [ __ ] d schneider
from twisted sister snap it towards
lunch yeah i said well i still remember
that commercial because i used to tape
mystery science theater off comedy
central back in the 90s and for a long
time i still had those videotapes and
they still the commercials on them
because i was too lazy to edit them out
so i remember seeing that commercial
every time i'd watched one of the
episodes you know i'd see that
commercial again
so yeah so a bunch of people that uh had
to do with like the team that that found
or transported uh utsi
ended up dying in mysterious ways
uh first of these
was a dude named ranier hen now this was
in 1992 which was less than a year after
the mummy was found
um now hen was actually heading the
forensic team that uh was examining the
mummy
and he was actually the first uh i think
he was the first person that actually
like touched the mummy um or had like
really close contact with it touched my
mommy loved him
oh my god
this is gonna take forever brought to
you by udo
holy [ __ ]
yeah
that's what i pictured i pictured it and
you know gears worthy yeah uh but yeah
so apparently uh rainier had picked up
the uh the body the mummy with his bare
hands to put it in a body bag
now
uh again this was not even a year after
the mummy was found
apparently um ranier hen was going to
give a lecture about
the iceman
and was in a car accident and died so he
was the first
victim of the supposed curse all right
not too long after that there was
another dude a mountaineer whose name
was kurt fritz
and he was the one that had led rainier
hen to the body
kurt fritz
died in an avalanche
now he was uh climbing a mountain with a
bunch of other people and so obviously
you know
everybody experienced the avalanche but
he was the only one that got killed even
though he was a very experienced
mountaineer look at what you're doing
yeah i'm becoming more gay
i kind of feel like all you need to do
now is just take that shirt off and then
put on just like a bow tie
[Laughter]
yeah
put a little choker on with it i have
one over there with like a little i got
one
[ __ ] yeah i got one of the little silver
ring on it
then i can like put a leash on it or
some [ __ ] like that i don't know
uh but yeah so kurt fritz this is the
second guy that's supposedly a victim of
the curse he died in avalanche was the
only member of his party that died uh
interestingly
a couple months after
uh fritz died
um there was a guy who was a he was
austrian like a journalist his his name
was also rainier but it was rainier uh
helzl now he was actually like a
filmmaker
and he was the only guy that had been
allowed to film uh the mummy being taken
off the mountain
uh so a couple months after fritz died
in the avalanche
rainier helsel died of a brain tumor and
he was only 47 years old and he had only
just put out a documentary
about like you utilizing all of the film
that he had taken like from the mountain
and stuff so that's three
then you have another guy helmut simon
now this guy was not a scientist but he
was actually a tourist he was german and
he was one of the uh original guys that
had like found he was up on the mountain
they were you know doing a
mountaineering trip and he was one of
the guys that actually found the mummy
first and you know told the authorities
about it
uh he was actually found dead
frozen in the ice in 2004 not far from
the spot where the mummy had been found
damn he must have committed suicide uh
they no they said there was a freak
blizzard and that he fell off a mountain
and uh you know so he wasn't trying to
take hootsie's place then i guess not
but how [ __ ] up is that this is like i
don't believe in curses and stuff i'm
just saying that from right now but some
of this stuff is kind of creepy i will
say that that's pretty creepy
um
and then
so so he died they found him and then
they have his funeral
less than an hour after his funeral this
other guy named dieter warnicky he was
the head of the rescue team that had
gone yeah
i knew we i knew you were going to be
about that
he was the head of the rescue team that
had gone to find the first guy
that guy also died of a heart attack he
just dropped dead so you know again
weird this is getting kind of weird
the year after that conrad spindler who
was an archaeologist he was the first
guy that had like kind of like inspected
the mummy's remains
now he is i don't know if this is true
this might have just been a rumor but he
was before any of this [ __ ] happened
he uh you know because there had been
like all this media about oh my god the
curse because by now like what five
people are dead now that had something
to do with finding the mummy and that's
kind of weird
um so he's kind of quoted as saying it's
all media hype the next thing you'll be
saying i will be next guess what he was
he had multiple sclerosis and he ended
up dying of that
uh so you know he had multiple i'm not
really sure actually i'm not really sure
but multiple sclerosis isn't isn't fatal
well i guess in that case what was the
complication yeah yeah yeah yeah that is
i think eventually fatal i was thinking
scoliosis of the spine that's what i was
thinking about yeah scoliosis is not
fatal
oh
yeah
oh my background well do you remember in
the 70s for whatever reason um they were
really like uh worried about scoliosis
yeah and i remember because i remember
being in i guess it was junior high yeah
they're constantly looking for it
yeah like so whenever you're a pe like
you always had to like you take your
shirt off and like just stand there in
your bra and you had your back straight
and you had well no you had to like uh
bend over at the waist and put your
hands together and then bend over and
they like somebody came and like looked
at your spine to see if your spine was
straight yeah as if they could do
anything about it something funny
i mean
i knew somebody that had it kind of bad
and they actually did have to wear a
brace for a while and then it did get
better
but it seems like most of the time
i don't know i know that it's a problem
that some people have that it's really
bad but it's just and you know it is
kind of like crippling but i kind of
feel like
what a weird thing to test for
when it seems like most of the time it
wouldn't really be all that much of a
big deal i don't know it's just very
very strange
terry's asking um
curious to know if there's any videos
out there that claim to be cursed if you
watched him yeah i think there was
but the videos they're talking about
wasn't the one where that guy made that
creepy ass movie that was [ __ ]
totally unintelligible but it was just
creepy [ __ ] black and white wasn't that
supposed to be cursed which one
i don't remember what it was called it
called but it was on the early internet
started seeing it in [ __ ]
late 90s
early 2000s
where they had
it looked like an old black and white
silent film and it was just really
[ __ ] creepy you couldn't tell if it
was them
uh if you if you don't recognize it you
talked about it before it's is it
begotten it might be begotten i don't
know it's worth it that came out in 1991
91 okay yeah that's i mean that was an
actual movie though it's like a movie
yeah it's a movie i've seen it wasn't
that supposed to be cursed
not that i heard but it's uh you know it
very well might be bits of it would show
up on the internet people didn't know
what it was yeah real [ __ ] creepy it
is creepy but like i said if you don't
that's what's kind of interesting is
that a lot of times
you know i i used to see like back in
the old days like in the early days of
the internet where you would see lurk or
the early days of youtube i should say
like mid 2000s so you would see like all
these like weird like little compilation
videos of like creepiest [ __ ] we found
around the internet and a lot of the
stuff they put in there was just from
clips from movies but they weren't
movies that were popular enough that
most people would recognize them and
most of them had clips from begotten in
there
um which like i said that was uh what's
that dude's name uh elias margie or
however pronounced his last name he's
the same guy that made shadow of the
vampire
and um
yeah so he put that out in 1991 it was
supposed to look like an old you know
it's supposed to look like an old silent
movie it's a silent movie but it came
out in the 90s and it is creepy as [ __ ]
it's very like nightmarish another uh
clip that turns up in a lot of those
kind of like creepy uh you know videos
and stuff back in the mid 2000s is that
scene from extro yeah where that alien
backwards where the alien with the
backwards legs like runs across which is
a really creepy scene but i've seen that
i've seen like paranormal channels
like putting that up on their thing as
like an ostensibly real creature
sighting and i'm like that's totally
from a movie that's from extra yeah
there's one out there that get mixes up
with that extra thing of a
video and it's from brazil
of what looks like a creature walking
across the ground downtown brazil and it
looks fake or something from but it
isn't it's real it's
a person in brazil
the guy that has a genetic disease that
makes him four-legged and it does look
like a
like a an alien dog or something
walking have you seen that one
i think i know what you're talking about
real creepy looking but it people go oh
it's fake no it's real
it's a person walking on all fours and
the arms and legs are short like a like
a foot long each one of them
and just the way the body's
real arched back arch backwards and
stuff just crazy looking it looks like
that thing from extra
but unfortunately that's a real person
yeah it's just a person walking home
with that disease
on all fours that would suck a lot yeah
and like the feet
had feet that could face the right way
so you could walk on all fours
just i yeah i have seen other people
with that disorder as well
yeah you know but it's not special
effects people go nuts fake no it isn't
yeah
well yeah i mean
i told you like several years ago i read
a book called mutants and it was
basically
you know it was genetic science so it
was each chapter was telling about um
different chromosomes like what would
happen
uh
if this particular thing went wrong on
this chromosome or whatever and um some
of the [ __ ] in there one the uh the
disfigurements and stuff like that were
horrifying and two they were like way
more common than you think yeah so
i mean some of the ones i can't remember
like any of the numbers but i remember
like reading some of the [ __ ] and being
like holy [ __ ] it's only like one in 500
births or something which is like
nothing
it's just it's scary so uh dj maniac
says it's like the old skinny puppy
video for warlock it was banned for
years and no one knew what was on it
turns out it's all horror movie clips
they couldn't secure the rights to
that's what i mean i kind of feel like
that there was so much of that and you
know there were so many kind of obscure
horror movies back in the day and if you
could kind of
you know before everybody could see
pretty much anything they wanted to and
could figure out where it came from
particularly like i said in the early
days of youtube people were posting all
kind of like movie clips as real [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and extra
that's like the example that i feel like
the most because that that came up on
like a bunch of different
characters
tom looks like the village people i look
at the do you see that i look like the
indian guy collectively like yeah
i look like the lineman
you
know
okay yeah i look at the village people
like all of them yeah all of the
villagers yeah that's okay
i guess he wasn't here for the beginning
of the show
where he jumps in where you decided well
i decided yeah to wear this
i'm wearing this [ __ ] for zach and my
gay fan
all right
thank you hey i'm sure they appreciate
it of course they appreciate this [ __ ]
they know a hot [ __ ] when they
see him
he
[Laughter]
like i said he let him have more drinks
he's gonna be back there gyrating
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what actually the app i
downloaded was all different
like creepy horror movie
uh ringtones i'm looking at myself on
the camera and the only thing i [ __ ]
need is an eye patch one of you [ __ ]
[ __ ] need to send me an ipad i think
you need a fuzzy ipad yeah like an ipad
i think that would be cool yeah i'll be
even [ __ ] more hardcore
the gays would love it even more and
then you could like you could put like a
big scar on the side yeah and i need a
big [ __ ] cigar and [ __ ]
in the background
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah
grab this hammer said pretty sure 90s
music is cursed corn olympus get kid
rock yeah i would agree with that zach
says i'm still not as type zack you
[ __ ] fickle [ __ ]
wants a chance are you upset yeah i'm
[ __ ] up with you
now my [ __ ] sensibilities are hurt oh
okay oh okay
oh my god why why does that keep the
horror movie keeps calling me
uh billy lane says the busby chair is my
favorite cursed object oh i'm going to
get to that i think that's one of the
last things like on my list though but
i'll definitely harness that assless
chaps how many times do i [ __ ] tell
you
all chaps are assless if they weren't
asless they wouldn't be chaps you wear
chaps over your [ __ ] jeans it's just
more fun to say
yeah
i mean you know
it's just more fun to say that's all
murder chord it returns i stole a real
eye patch from a one-eyed dude i'll send
it next time
i need is a mustache now i'm gonna get
one of them things look like a like a
max von scidow [ __ ] fu manchu from
[ __ ] from [ __ ] yeah what do they call
it what do they call that a van dyke
yeah is that called the van dyke that
little thing with the like the pointy
beard i actually considered uh growing
one out but
man i always shave in the shower and
[ __ ] i got in this bad habit of just
[ __ ] emptying in the shower and
shaving without thinking about like oh
that's right i was going to let [ __ ]
grow out yeah i thought you were talking
about that for one time and then i was
just kind of like i think maybe you let
it go for like one or two days and i was
like what happened to that forget about
it yeah
[Laughter]
i mean that habit of just [ __ ]
shaving in the shower i shaved my head
too in the shower so i'm in the habit of
doing that
i shaved my whole body in the shower i
got a [ __ ] video up on [ __ ] only
fans for that
zach's footprints all over it
all his likes and [ __ ]
zach said i can half of the gay army
zach said it zach said if tom was a tall
ginger danish guy with the same outfit
we'd be having a different conversation
you know you like jewish dudes
he takes jewish dudes
yeah
little little good jewish boys with
their yarmulkes
i haven't seen it yeah
that's the gay version of a [ __ ]
of a [ __ ] catholic school girl that's
what all that is all right i can see
that
i i wouldn't know
yeah
uh but yeah so where okay where was i
all right so this guy here now to see
this is what
this is what you should do like when
several people have died from a supposed
curse
don't go out there in public and be like
it's all [ __ ] it's you know what's
it gonna get me next
yeah because then it did it's just like
a [ __ ] movie so yeah that guy died
too after he said uh you know that he
was gonna be next haha
uh so the next guy was a guy named dr
tom loy
now he was the one that carried out the
dna analysis and he was actually the one
that discovered that um that uti had not
been alone when he died so that was kind
of like a big deal
um so he was actually writing a book
about this very thing like about all
these discoveries that he had made uh
when he was found dead in his home in
brisbane uh presumably australia at the
age of 63.
not really sure what he died of they
said he'd been in uh good health prior
to that
so
they just found him dead don't know if
it was a heart attack stroke i don't
really know what it is but so that's uh
seven people if you're counting within
not really that long a time like i said
i don't believe in this stuff but
that is kind of creepy and weird
um
but the thing about curses though and
i'll kind of get into this when we talk
about the king tucker's too is that
yeah when you look at
all the people that you know had
something to do with finding this mummy
finding it you know extracting it
studying it writing books about it
whatever the hell filming it
um
that's a lot of people
so within any large enough group
you know you're gonna get like some
deaths just from a statistical point of
view and i kind of feel like people
don't take into account too like all the
people that had to do with finding the
mummy and stuff like that that didn't
die that just you know what i mean which
was probably a lot more and like i said
we'll talk about that like too with the
king tut thing because the king tuck
curse is like super super famous
but when you kind of like look at it
yeah it's weird that you know x amount
of people died that had something to do
with that but when you think about all
the people that had something to do with
it that didn't die it's like a way
bigger number so
it's just you know statistics that's all
it is i mean it is kind of weird like
how that one guy like died sort of where
the mummy was
like just from falling off a mountain
and then freezing in almost the same
spot that's weird but you know like
coincidences happen
so uh so yeah so the legend is still
continuing he's uh i guess the iceman
you can still see him at the museum i
think in uh bolzano italy and uh he gets
like a whole bunch of visitors i mean
unless it's been closed since but uh you
know as far as i know you can still go
see him
all right so let's talk about another
mummy uh well let's talk about king tut
now one thing i will note i do kind of
feel like a lot of [ __ ] like with movies
and stuff like that is you know mummy's
curse this and that
but
in real life
uh most tombs don't really have curses
on them that's really i mean
it has happened they have found some
tombs that had curses on them but it's
not really all that common you know what
i'm saying
so i kind of feel like maybe that's more
like an invention of or you know they
took something that was like happened
once in a blue moon and like blew it up
into this big thing like every single
tomb that you find like has a curse on
it now
um there are a couple
uh you know mostly from the old kingdom
like you do like this one and it's funny
too because the curses didn't get really
bad until later i kind of feel like the
old ones
were kind of like there was like curses
but then it wasn't like for death or
anything they're just like well you know
you won't have any kids or you know [ __ ]
like that it was just kind of lame stuff
but uh there is there is a tomb of uh
ankatifi
who is around the uh 10th dynasty
and his tomb does actually have a curse
on it sort of uh it says any ruler who
shall do evil or wickedness to this
coffin awakens to the coffin may hemen
uh who was a kind of local deity not
accept any goods he offers and may his
heir not inherit so
it's a curse but it's not really it's
like nobody wants your [ __ ]
the end dude that's like the worst that
could happen so you know what i mean
they're all kind of like that type of
thing there's also another one uh
kentika
ikeki i guess i'm pronouncing that right
from the sixth dynasty
and his curse says as for all men who
shall enter this my tomb there will be
judgment
uh or i guess like some kind of impurity
like it's just the word impure there
will be judgment and end shall be made
for him i shall seize his neck like a
bird i shall cast the fear of myself
into him so i don't really know if he's
implying that he's gonna kill the person
or if he's gonna grab him by the neck
and be like
and you know just like scaring him or
whatever
so
like i said not super super common
now
when they very famously found the tomb
of king tutankhamun in the 1920s
the story went around
that um
that there was a stone in front of the
tomb
that had uh you know this curse on it
and usually this curse is quoted as
death shall come on swift wings to him
who disturbs the peace of the king
i added that last part um that's
actually not true that was like a later
uh you know kind of
fabrication there was actually no curse
on tut's tomb um it didn't say any of
that
but that kind of got uh you know
added to the story later after people
started dying
uh so yeah so you got howard carter uh
the egyptologist and lord carnarvon who
was the guy who was uh you know funding
the expedition so they opened the tomb
in 1922
and then weird [ __ ] started happening
apparently
so you have another egyptologist james
breasted
yeah i knew yeah
again every time i go through the notes
and i'm just like oh tom's gonna chuckle
at that
he's breasted
i mean men have breasts too
yeah oh
where did he get this
that was his name
i didn't i didn't name him that
that's his name how did that name appear
the most [ __ ] must been working
out he must've been jacked he had big
old [ __ ] pecs and they go he has
breasted that man is blessed
and then you inherit that name
maybe that's what it was
yeah i'm not a good thing i didn't hear
if i inherited the name of my
grandfather because that [ __ ]
had forearms like popeye they would have
called him tom the popeyed
the popeye the popeye or some weird [ __ ]
that had been really funny you thought
i've been your last name yeah he said he
i kept here i heard that from a lot of
his friends he had forearms like popeye
yeah could he squeeze a spinach can and
then like eat it out of there
that little dude
i heard stories but i never met him he
was dead by the time i was born you know
died of my dad was a teenager just saw
photographs of him
part of his life he had he owned a hobby
shop in mississippi and he was like a
champion
thrower of model gliders he used to like
to make model gliders
and he would win all kinds of
championships in the local area because
he could throw those gliders [ __ ]
further than other people could and it
was because he had the big old forearms
over there that's what that was that's
the story
but he can make balsam with gliders
that's pretty cool yeah models yeah they
were like real [ __ ] you know they had
like seven eight-foot wingspans yeah i
remember having one of those for like
well i mean from a toy store back in the
whole day that you kind of like put
together yourself back in the back in
the early days you know you're talking
about 50s and [ __ ] you had to make them
you had to cut them out of sheet wood
woods the balsa wood sheets yeah you
know all by hand and glue them together
yeah i think later on like i had one
that you just bought all this stuff
pre-cut and then you just put it
together yeah no that's not what they
were talking about back then
it was
you bought the model was nothing more
than um
a bunch of sheets of
of
[ __ ] balsa wood and a bunch of paper
plans and you cut the plans out and
pinned them onto the balsa wood cut it
out with a yeah with a um
x-acto knife you laid them all out and
glued it all together with like elmer's
glue
it took weeks to make one and it had wet
had spars and supports it was just like
making a real airplane
you know it had as many you know had
hundreds of parts
and just to make this little glider
i would never have the patience but back
in those days they had patience for that
well i mean they didn't really have all
of these other like distractions and
stuff so they took you know they would
they would do stuff that took like but
he owned a shop that sold all kinds of
stuff like that he owned a lot of shops
over time
yeah yeah he had a grocery store
no no his dad owned a great grocery
store he owned a photography shop and a
hobby shop and then a gun shop with guns
that guns and fishing equipment stuff
sporting goods pretty good job
all right so let's get back to henry
breasted james and re-breasted
[Laughter]
james the big brother
yeah sorry dude
um
yeah so thank you zach what is it uh
it's interesting how ancient egypt
inspired makeup and fashion decor in the
20s and that look would filter down to
inspire goth style later on yes that's
absolutely true that's why you got a lot
of uh kind of
yeah like ancient egyptian looking i
mean after they found the tomb in 1922 i
mean ancient egypt style like totally
had a moment you know what i mean like
with all the the eye makeup and all that
kind of stuff yeah yeah yeah and they
were into that since the late 1800s yeah
people were into egyptology
it wasn't they couldn't read any of
those hieroglyphs until
the time of um
napoleon napoleon when he found the
stella the rosetta rosetta stone i've
seen that in london and then they were
able to piece together what all that
stuff said so there was a whole scene of
doing seances and [ __ ] magic and
underground rally type [ __ ] based upon
ancient egyptian magic because you could
[ __ ] your way through it because
they didn't know what in that stuff said
they just knew it was a great
civilization that did all this neat
stuff and left all this stuff behind you
could use your imagination on it
if you look at it now it's pretty
mundane though it's just a great
civilization you know like all the other
ones you know rome and
eventually america will be remembered
like that for a while probably uh you
know
but uh yeah they had a good look they
had a look to the some of the drawings
in the new kingdom kind of looked the
art deco which was real
popular in the 20s so it kind of came
back into fashion it kind of merged but
it wasn't always like that just 20s
i mean honestly i've seen a lot of um
you know ancient egyptian artifacts like
they have like a huge section at the at
the met in new york
and um you know they have big chunks of
like tombs and stuff like that and that
[ __ ] is like
amazing and a lot of it is like was
really well preserved yeah and it had
kind of a futuristic look to it yeah
they they had a
they had a had a motif going yeah yeah
and it's just it well it's interesting
how
uh consistent their artwork because
obviously it was you know thousands of
different artists probably but they
really had kind of
yeah you can tell the difference between
different dynasties and stuff but
it's not really as different as i mean
you know the look of it was like very
consistent old kingdom and middle
kingdom didn't quite have the look
you're talking about most of the look
that you're talking about was new
kingdom
and that was all valley of the kings
that era
and the the pyramids
which you know some of those pyramids
didn't have that look took them a long
time to perfect that
yeah because some of the early ones are
kind of like janky looking yeah they
weren't they weren't pyramids really
not perfect they're just kind of like a
pile of rocks yeah
and they were like different angles in
them and [ __ ] because they they were
making it up as they weren't they were
just kind of making those up as they
were going they didn't have a science
forum it wasn't until later when the
great pyramids down the giza plateau
those were built upon the science that
worked it took them a while to figure
that out
there's lots of them i'm just laughing
because i'm like thinking of like the
king that commissioned like some of the
first pyramids and he comes out to the
work site to look at and he's like
not really what i was expecting but
you know noble effort i guess
[Laughter]
there was a whole industry making those
yeah i just like i just he comes out and
he's like expecting like this really
cool like fabulous and it's just kind of
like
it's like
it just looks like a big pile of [ __ ]
rocks
but uh yeah so so uh here's breasted
again
now he didn't chuckle that time okay
so so breasted
he um
because was working with howard carter
right
now he says this is his story
he says not too long after the tomb was
opened uh this was supposedly like the
beginning of the curse or whatever even
though nobody well not a person died in
this but you know
so he says that howard carter sent a
messenger back to his own house like on
some kind of errand or so like hey go
get me something or whatever
now the messenger said that when he got
close to the house he heard something
that sounded like a
human cry or something that sounded like
that
so then he goes in the house and he sees
that there's a bird cage in there and
inside the bird cage
is a cobra
and inside the cobra's mouth is howard
carter's pet canary
so apparently so the story went around
that the cobra which is actually a
symbol of the egyptian monarchy
was
invading the house of howard carter the
guy who had defiled the tomb and went in
there and ate his [ __ ]
you know canary
i mean because that was like supposedly
the same day uh so this was actually
reported in the paper at the time sounds
like a fabrication it sounds like a
[ __ ] story i mean it's a good story
but i don't think that [ __ ] really
happened i mean how the [ __ ] would a
cobra get in your i mean you know i
don't know i guess it could happen but
that seems a little coincidental
so uh so like i said this was reported
and it was supposedly like oh [ __ ] we've
kind of like you know [ __ ] around with
forces we don't understand here comes
the cobra ancient egypt's gonna come
kick our asses not too long after that
what are you looking at what happened to
that rgb
oh i don't know
it's been on for a really long time
maybe it just burned out it went out i
mean you know
yep
it's got power
larry martin says noble effort lol he
probably slaughtered those workers yeah
he probably did he comes and he's like
what is this [ __ ] and he just kills
all of them and then gets another get
another crew in here get it i want it
straight like a pyramid uh but yeah so
the first person that died i wonder why
they did that i don't know
was it blue
uh i don't really remember honestly
i i just i leave them on all the time so
i don't really know i mean it's good
enough i don't think it was but it
doesn't really matter
um
you know
he's back there [ __ ] with it
that's really weird maybe because what
maybe king tut did it i don't know what
happened
that makes sense more like that
okay
uh so the first person that died the
first uh person's death that's
attributed to the uh king tut's curse is
lord carnarvon uh one of the first
people him and howard carter are the
first people into the tomb and lord
carnarvon was also the guy that funded
the expedition
uh earlier before the tomb was opened he
had actually been bitten by a mosquito i
think it was on his face like on his
cheek
uh and later he actually uh while he was
shaving he actually cut the bite open
and it ended up getting infected and he
got blood poisoning
and died of it
now
the story goes
that
when they did an autopsy on king tut's
mummy
that he also he had a a healed up wound
on his cheek
but they didn't know they couldn't
remember like which cheek like lord
carnarvon's bite was on but it kind of
went into the lore that he got this bite
on the mosquito bite on his cheek that
was in the same place that king tut had
one you know what i mean so there was
that kind of whole thing but i mean it
seems like a [ __ ] up way to die just
getting a mosquito bite and then cutting
it open when you're shaving oh oops and
then you get blood poisoning and [ __ ]
drop dead but you know what i mean
so yeah so that happened that was first
uh death
and then uh after that happened and like
i said the the story about the cobra had
been reported then lord carnarvon died
and of course the media was like what
the [ __ ] and everybody was like mommy's
curse and then sir arthur conan doyle uh
you know famously who was you know he
created sherlock holmes but then he was
like really into paranormal [ __ ] too
like he was all into spiritualism and
whatnot
um so it's weird because sherlock holmes
was like so logical but sir arthur conan
doyle was like so gullible which like
that i don't know that always like
cracks me up him and uh houdini were
like good friends though
even though they had completely opposite
views about spiritualism but that's a
whole fascinating we should do another
show about that i think we did one about
houdini a long time ago but uh so he
thought his theory was that lord
carnarvon uh had died
because
they're because they had loosed some
elemental spirits from the tomb because
apparently
uh the priests that have buried toot in
common had like
conjured up these elementals like to
guard against like whoever was open in
the [ __ ] and so sir arthur conan doyle
a grown-ass person a grown ass believed
yeah the elementals were on the tube and
killed the dude with the mosquito bite
so there you go
uh 1925
another dude an anthropologist named
henry field
um he went with uh old mr breasted
and they went to visit the tomb
now he said that
howard carter had given his friend sir
bruce ingram this present and the
present was a mummified hand
presumably from the tomb was it tut's
hand was it one of his slaves i don't
really probably not yeah uh yeah cause
the
the mummy
yeah too valuable so but it was a
mummified hand and it had a scarab
bracelet on the wrist
now apparently there was a message on
the bracelet i don't know if this is
true or not uh that said cursed be he
who moves my body to him shall come fire
water and pestilence again sounds like
[ __ ] curse is very very rare in real
egyptian tombs um
you know i don't know if that was really
there that seems like it was added post
facto i'm just saying
uh but apparently bruce ingram
not too long after he got that present
from howard carter his house burned down
and then they rebuilt his house and then
it flooded
so you know again
sounds like a story i don't really know
it flooded but what type of flood are we
talking about yeah i don't know like a
flash flood i'm not sure we're talking
about some water ran into it
see that's the thing too and and i read
this like somebody pointed this out
that when you're talking about curses
you know it would be one thing if
everybody that touched you know x item
whatever uh you know died a horrible
death like immediately or
you know 24 hours within 24 hours or
something yeah that would be maybe
something to investigate but a lot of
curses seem to work like you don't
necessarily even have to die you just
have to kind of suffer misfortune and
it's not even just you it could also be
your family membership
which like i said that's what i mean so
honestly like it could be so that's like
a huge pool yeah not only of people but
it's like a huge pool of like
possibilities and of time because
there's not really a cut off that's
right yeah you know what i'm saying so
you wait around long enough something
bad's gonna happen the curse doesn't
happen right because bad things happen
to pretty much everybody like if you
wait around long enough i i hate to tell
you that's not right i'm gonna fix him
okay he's gonna fix it
but um
you know it's just so it's just kind of
like
you know i like reading about this stuff
because it's creepy but i don't really
think that uh you know and some of the
stuff i think was added later just to
make it a better story because some of
this stuff is not real uh you know not
real sourced
uh so a next guy who
supposedly died um
from the curse was george j gould the
first
now he didn't really have anything to do
with like
uh you know
opening the tomb but he did actually go
visit it
uh but he apparently got a fever or some
kind of illness while he was in the tomb
or that's what they always say anyway
and he ended up dying in the french
riviera in may of 1923 which like i said
yeah about a year or so after the after
the tomb was open
uh another guy who was on carter's
excavation team named ac mace
uh he actually died in 1928 and see now
we're going like six years out okay so
i'm we're getting like less and less
plausible as it goes on
um he actually died of pneumonia i
believe but like i said that was six
years after the tomb was open
this one's pretty weird though captain
the honorable richard bethel who is
howard carter's secretary
he died in 1929 again seven years after
the tomb was open so
now he died in bed in a club in mayfair
so i guess london somewhere
and wikipedia says the victim of a
suspected smothering
they didn't say whether the smothering
was accidental like he just rolled over
in his sleep and like the pillow
suffocated him or whether some
[ __ ] came in his room and
suffocated him with a pillow or
something like that
but
yeah so he smothered uh and maybe was
murdered
now howard carter who you think would be
if he believed in any of this stuff
which he didn't
uh would have been like well [ __ ] man i
was the first one in there and it's my
name associated with it so you'd think
if the curse was gonna get anybody that
would get him but it didn't
uh he actually died 16 years after the
tomb was opened
uh so not a curse but yeah but still if
you read stuff like some people still
say oh well he was a victim of the curse
i'm like 16. that was 16 years later how
old was he uh he was 64 when he died
and he had lymphoma what
so curse my again that has nothing to do
with the curse like i said he just died
like normally
15 years that's a normal lifespan yeah
that's what i see back then yeah
uh so
so again and this is what we're talking
about we talk about statistics of the 58
people who were present
when the tomb and sarcophagus were open
we're not even talking about like all
the random ass people that just wandered
in there afterward or you know or
touched it or whatever 58 people that
were in there uh when the tomb and
sarcophagus were opened
only eight died within a dozen years
doesn't seem like a curse to me it
sounds creepy when you lay them all out
like that
but when you actually think of how long
a time that was and how many people that
were there that nothing bad happened to
then
yeah it starts to seem a little less
mysterious that's all i'm saying i've i
remember this case [ __ ] long time ago
like 30 years ago
yeah i read about it in my people were
like what are you talking about curse
and then when you look at the data
you're like yeah no not a curse
not a curse they're just laying it out
in books and then [ __ ] like in search
of and they're laying it out without
giving you exact [ __ ] details yeah
you don't really have a lot of content
when you look at it you're like no no
everything went normally
yeah dude didn't die early of a curse he
died normal lifespan for the time 65.
well most of them did like i said the
weirdest one there was just lord
carnarvon and that was just like she
seemed like just shitty look i mean that
seems like a shitty way to go
which you know something normal like you
get bit by a mosquito on your face and
then like you cut the wound open and
then you get blood poisoning you can die
i mean well that was a normal occurrence
back then but yeah back then it was i
mean nowadays that would be like super
unlucky but what year was that 1922 1923
uh so you had you had um
um antibiotics but not
not much else
because what is it um when did
antibiotics come in
ooh
late 1910s i think right something like
that yeah
so easy to get infected back then and
die
that's true
again that's why i think penicillin was
correct me people go in there and check
when was penicillin in wide use i think
that was later because we talked about
that a little bit on our tuskegee
syphilis
experiment i think penicillin had been
around for a bit but i think um
it didn't really get into wide usage
until like the 40s okay then i don't
think then then that's not the curse
that's just him not having access to
knowledge of penicillin and he was a
lord and he uh financed the whole
excavation so his ass was rich right and
he still died in a stupid way like that
right just goes to common back then he
got infected he died yeah so even with
all his money he couldn't do anything
about it holy crap
um
well the knowledge wasn't there yeah
camp guys said they say tut but was
buried quickly and in a vacant tomb
because he died unexpectedly it wasn't a
vacancy that's why there's not many
decorations in the tomb just drawings of
baboons
uh no
it's
no we're talking about his tomb wasn't
extravagant but it wasn't
it wasn't bare
yeah there was a lot of [ __ ] in there
i've seen photos of it from the time it
was just kind of like a second echelon
burial
yeah he was he wasn't uh he wasn't king
for long he was young well yeah he was
only what was he like 18 when he died
yeah he was only king for a few years
yeah so he got a proper burial for a
king of his age for the time that he
served
it wasn't unusual
camp guys said can you imagine finding
those burial nested caskets with those
solid gold masks beyond believe yeah i
can't even imagine i mean even if they
had some inkling of what was in there
because they knew about ancient egyptian
tombs it's just they hadn't really found
one that hadn't been
uh rifled through right that's that's
why
that's why we have tuts too yeah is
because he was a
second third echelon king he wasn't
famous his tomb was never found
you know
by robbers yeah yeah the main kings
their tombs were found long long ago
yeah and most of the good [ __ ] was taken
out yeah
had he been somebody like ramses oh he'd
have been robbed [ __ ]
within the lifetime of somebody who knew
about ramses yeah you know so
no there's nothing unusual about finding
king tub's tomb he wasn't a main player
and even in his day
he just died too young yeah he wasn't a
bad king so we were all like well he
must have not been any good or this no
it's just he wasn't king for very long
yeah because like he was very very young
he was just a kid really he died and was
quickly forgotten
and like i said most of us yeah and i
mean that's and the only reason people
remember him now and he's famous
nowadays is because his tomb well no
because his tomb was found intact that's
what i'm saying he wasn't important
right if he was important his tomb would
have not been found attacked
yeah right the important ones were but
there was a bunch of cool [ __ ] in there
yeah yeah still good yeah still good he
was buried with ranks with honor i mean
that mask is like [ __ ] amazing you
know but he was not an amazing god king
yeah an amazing god king would have been
ramses all right
and there are huge complexes left for
ramsay's sons being buried and [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] he was the joseph
stalin of ancient egypt
uh just but you'll never find ramsay's
tomb that that [ __ ] well no
well when i think they might have found
ramsay's tomb it might have been that
big complex but robbed a long long long
time ago
rob robbed in in the ancient era yeah
because he just [ __ ] called too
much attention to himself well i mean
everybody like criminals back then were
kind of like which is like they're just
waiting for them to die like we're gonna
[ __ ] we're gonna bust in there and get
all that [ __ ] tomb of ramses oh yeah
we're gonna get that there's me all kind
of good right there
so yeah out of all the out of all the
egyptian
god kings ramses was the main one
all right that was the archetype
for ancient egypt
yeah
all right um yeah larry says he should
have kept that cut cleaner yeah i guess
they didn't really i don't know they
didn't really worry about it back then i
don't really know well they they buried
them all down in the
valley of the kings which in ancient
times was guarded
but
guarding things is hard to do over time
especially when you have governments
that go unstable and that lose funding
you're talking about centuries
you know
you just can't guard something
well over the centuries and then
millennia
thousands of years
most of ancient egypt died or started
vanished in the islamic era
because a lot of it got looted to make
mosques like the
the outside coverings of of all the
pyramids it's a bunch of limestone there
and they made moss out of that
um
and they went in there and found a lot
any tomb that wasn't robbed they went in
there and got that later because you
know just new empires form and they
don't really respect the old empires
they have new
religions new beliefs they go oh those
are pagans we're going to tear their
[ __ ] down same thing in europe all the
all the [ __ ] roman stuff got
cannibalized in the medieval period most
of it most of what we know of ancient
rome
was found in the attics of
of european lords
all those statues they were in private
collections european noblemen had all
that
it eventually ended up in museums but
it was all being looted you know
[ __ ] looters
well what's it gonna do
imagine
half of detroit is gone torn down that
was that one time the greatest city in
america
all right
but most of it's gone now torn down
people aren't saving pieces of detroit
it's just being lost
but a thousand years from now a statue
from downtown detroit will be worth
something
and there'll be might be a few people
out there that have somehow
saved a [ __ ] statue that used to
stand downtown detroit
you know
you just gave a bunch of people ideas
hey we're going to go to detroit like oh
yeah
well a lot of people are going to like
steal a mailbox or something yeah
most uh you know got grapplers in the in
the in the audience we remember old
detroit back when it was ruins and they
were tearing it down and
if you go to most of all detroit now has
been returned to nature it's just an
open plane
because you know they took bulldozers
and [ __ ] tore it all down beautiful
homes [ __ ] handmade
handmade [ __ ] you know hearths over
the damn
fireplaces and bricks and
doorknobs that were just [ __ ]
gorgeous doorknobs made out of brass and
all these fittings and
it's all gone but i remember it as a kid
but there was a lot of that back in
those days and over the years people
just said as just more junk from detroit
they just could throw it away you know
well it's just kind of like when you
move in a house and then you find a
bunch of [ __ ] in the attic and he's like
[ __ ] on it yeah and take it to goodwill
or throw it in
exactly and most of ancient egypt went
that way
yeah it's like it's funny to think about
now yes but back then they were just
kind of like yeah this is old [ __ ] yeah
yeah this whole [ __ ] statue of this
dude [ __ ] him you know
a lot of some of the statues that were
found was found in a damn buried theater
during the time of uh what's his name
nero because a lot of the a lot of stuff
got buried during the time of nero to
build a new housing stuff they found a
theater that had been buried and
something built on top of it
and when they broke into it i think it
might have been 18th century 19th
century uh brand new fresh statues still
sitting there on the podium of emperors
in the theater
and there wasn't any names underneath
them they don't know who they were they
just know they were emperors
you know a lot of those statues of
[ __ ]
because you know they were we don't have
the context in those days people knew
who those emperors were yeah like if you
saw a photograph of reagan you know who
that is if you see a photograph of
[ __ ] clinton you know who that is you
know they didn't need to put names
underneath them
uh but some of the [ __ ] great statues
that are now in theaters can't now in
museums came from that theater
they're not really quite sure who they
were
you know responsible it was a long time
ago long time ago right you know they
know they were emperors they're just not
sure which one
you know
yeah because no they didn't have
photographs right right
danny rowley ghostface says there should
be a horror film about a serial object
cursor who curses objects and leaves
them in public to be found and turn
people's lives upside down for the worse
because i'd watch it that's actually a
really good idea i'm surprised somebody
hasn't made that uh mr upon it thank you
mr roboto death at 65 after pyramid very
much a mommy curse yeah right okay uh
camp guy said wonder who got those
rembrandts from the gardner museum i
actually
i don't think we're ever gonna find that
stuff um i kind of want to do a show
about that because that's i'm really
interested in like art theft and art
forgery and stuff and uh
that
it sucks that those uh that those guys
took all those paintings but
it's kind of like in a way all those
kind of heist things i always kind of
like admire their ingenuity at least
even though it's like shitty and you
know please don't do that but i don't
know like there was another one too that
happened it wasn't art it was actually
diamonds and well diamonds and gems
and it happened in uh belgium it was
like in antwerp
and
that i read a whole book about it and
just the lengths that this gang went to
to steal it took him like two years and
they had a mole on the inside and it's
like just all the planning and [ __ ] like
that and it was just fascinating and
most of them actually got away with it i
don't think they found any of the stuff
they found like some of the you know
kind of because they stole a bunch of
stuff like it was mostly gems but you
know because i guess it was like the
diamond district in belgium there
uh let's see okay so
i want to talk about
uh the cursed paintings because we were
going to talk about these on the urban
legend show and we just were going on
for so long that we didn't get around to
it
so uh i wanted to kind of like um cover
a couple of these as well
so uh probably the most famous cursed
painting nowadays
is a painting that's called the hands
resist him
now i have a picture of this actually i
don't i usually forget to do this kind
of [ __ ] but i do actually have the
painting today uh this isn't all of it
this is just kind of like the the main
part of it but this is it here
which is it's very creepy
uh yeah that's it it's called the hands
resistant
and uh this is a supposedly cursed uh
haunted painting
so story behind this one uh is
goes thusly
so this painting they actually know who
painted it was a dude named bill stone
stonehenge stoneham stoneham
now he painted it back in 1972.
now even though the painting looks
creepy as [ __ ] uh i will admit that
but according to the artist
um
that what it means
is that he's like the little boy in it
is supposed to be him like as a little
kid
uh the door behind that has all the hand
prints on it uh he said that's supposed
to be like a representation
of
the uh kind of the the door between the
waking world and the world of like
fantasy or dreams or whatever
uh and then the doll is supposedly the
guide still pretty weird um you know but
it's maybe not as creepy as it appears
so this painting had been kind of like
circulating for a while because like i
said it was painted in 1972
it came became famous in 2000
when somebody posted it for sale
on ebay
and the description of it implied very
strongly that it was cursed slashed
haunted and had all kind of weird [ __ ]
about it
now the painting uh was first displayed
at a gallery in beverly hills in 1972
not too long after it was painted this
was like a one-man show like the artist
and uh the show was actually even
reviewed by the los angeles times art
critic at the time
during the show this particular painting
the hands resist him was uh bought by an
actor named john marley who was actually
uh in the godfather
and after marley died uh they're not
really entirely sure where the painting
ended up apparently it ended up with
family members or got given away or
whatever
uh the painting actually ended up
getting found um at an old brewery
by this old couple in california and
they were the ones that put the painting
up on ebay
uh in february of 2000 what
nothing oh i thought you oh no no no
didn't your drink oh okay i thought you
i wanted to say something no i thought
you wanted to like answer a question
uh so yeah so february 2000 this turns
up on an auction now according to the
sellers this elderly couple
uh who had found the painting
they said that it was cursed they said
that the characters in the paint i love
this that the characters in the painting
moved around at night what like i guess
you would like get up and the character
and the and the people were in different
positions than they were earlier no i'm
not either it's a good story though like
i said i mean it's extraordinary it was
a good way to like get to get some money
for the painting because you know uh but
yeah so and they said too that the
characters could actually come out of
the painting and like walk around in the
room and [ __ ] okay
uh now i didn't see the photographs that
supposedly uh accompanied this ebay
listing
but apparently they included some photos
that were supposedly proof they're like
hey look
uh you know this is this is proof that
the people move around or that they come
out of the painting at night or whatever
um
the the photographs
they said that there was this incident
where the little doll in the painting
threatened the
boy with a gun she was holding which the
artist said that's not a gun it's a dry
cell battery like with wires coming out
but whatever it doesn't even look like a
gun
but uh so she threatened him with the
gun and he tried to get out of the
painting so they said that that's what
the what the photos were showing that
the doll was like get out of the
painting right now you know yeah it was
that
uh so
they also included and honestly these
two were kind of like geniuses because
um you know if you're gonna sell
something on ebay you don't think you're
gonna get that much money for it just
say it's like cursed or haunted or some
[ __ ] and like people will be all kind of
then you get all kinds of i'm trying to
sell a dipping box yeah this is i kind
of feel like well after that debit box
story like got popular
and it was on haunting and stuff i kind
of feel like a lot of people did that
and that for a while there was this is
going back many years but for a while i
feel like there was a trend for
ghosts in a jar
you know what i mean like where you'd
have a jar they got girls selling farts
jars full of farts i mean you can sell
anything to anybody you can i know yeah
well i you know what um
honestly if you can get somebody to pay
for that more power to you more power
more power to respect your hustle i do i
do as well like i said it's not i don't
have a problem i don't think they should
take that down or anything oh let a girl
sell farts i don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i mean you know if dudes are that if you
got sick the dudes out there simping
that much where they're gonna buy a fart
out of a jar
i'm a [ __ ] i'm gonna send that woman
a tip i'm gonna give her some kudos
because that
i respect her [ __ ] game yeah
yeah i respect your game
uh thank you again mr roboto tom and
jenny do you think james dean's car is
cursed no no probably not no matter of
fact
that car was [ __ ] totaled
and they got it was just
turned it was just a little [ __ ] ball
of twisted
metal but they still have collectors
looking for it
i think it's long gone
yeah probably
but if you have that car
you could probably make a million bucks
on that car oh i'm sure
uh they would buy that wreck
and somehow try to straighten that frame
out of it and build an entire car on
that [ __ ] straightened ass down i
don't know how you could straighten it i
saw the photographs
but they would try to build a car based
on that frame around that serial number
and rebuild that car and it would
auction for a lot that would be james
dean's [ __ ] spider
james dean sports porsche spider which
was a cool car
but i looked into that way back in the
day
james dean supports the spider was
[ __ ] curled up into a [ __ ] ball
and thrown away and then melted down
it's it's gone
nobody thought it would be collectible
not in those days well i mean that's the
very thing that makes things collectible
later on is that nobody thought to keep
it at the time because nobody even like
it never occurred to anybody that even
his friends and family or whatever
weren't interested in it
so it's gone it's long which i mean i
can see that like if your loved one was
killed in a car you don't want to
[ __ ] keep the [ __ ] goddamn but the
collectors are looking for it they know
the serial number of that car
they know what that car looks like
if you could fake that wreck
you'd make a lot of money
good luck with that
don't get killed yeah there are
photographs and
i don't think you could fake it though
no i couldn't fake that wreck no
probably not i mean you might be able to
like sell it to somebody that wasn't all
that savvy about it people would get
involved but savvy [ __ ] would
get involved because it would be worth a
million at least
yeah but so uh so yeah so this car is
long gone this particular uh listing
uh which is another thing that you
should probably do if you're selling
some [ __ ] that's supposed to be haunted
on ebay
uh always have a disclaimer saying that
if some bad [ __ ] happens to you like the
curse you know does some bad [ __ ] to you
you can't sue us i mean it's just
probably just you know it's probably
good to like cover your ass like that so
uh so yeah so they have the thing so if
you buy it it's your ass we just you
know we're absolving ourselves the
liability of the whole thing so they did
that
so obviously
because this was 2 000 and everybody was
very cursed painting on ebay so the [ __ ]
went pretty much viral
and uh i think that the auction page got
viewed like 30 000 times some [ __ ] like
that
uh obviously some people came forward
and said just looking at the pictures
made me feel
nauseated there was that whole thing
now the first bit i'm not sure if they
had um
i don't know if this was one of the
things where they had like an aux i
don't know what the uh what the
first asking price was
uh but the first bid was 199
but um 30 people eventually uh bid on it
and it ended up selling for 1025
so not bad
um you know
not a million but you know
uh the person that bought it was
actually like a gallery owner
and so i don't think they were really
cared about it being haunted but they
just probably thought oh well people
come to the gallery to see it because
it's kind of like famous now so they
bought it and they actually got in touch
with uh bill stoneman the art the artist
and told him hey your [ __ ] was just on
ebay and they said the [ __ ] was haunted
and he actually
seemed like he hadn't heard about that
he's like huh isn't that crazy and uh
everybody was talking about like the
weird
interpretations they had of like what
the painting meant he's like that's
totally not what i meant but okay
whatever
and um
so uh
he said though i don't know if this is
true or if he's just like once he found
out about like the curse that he decided
he was gonna
uh go into the legend a little bit so he
could like sell some more artwork which
like i said i don't blame him but he's
like oh yeah now that you mention it
um the guy that owned the gallery where
i first showed the painting back in 1972
and the art critic that covered that
show back in 1972 both of them died
within a year of like seeing the
painting so like i said that to me
sounds like
a sounds like a yarn
uh because he's trying to get like more
he's just feeding into the [ __ ] which
like i said i don't blame him he's an
artist he probably like needs some
[ __ ] money you know
uh so what ended up happening after that
was that whoever uh a person that saw
like the story about the original
painting so they contacted the artist
and they said hey you should paint and
he commissioned a sequel to the painting
so he painted another one and it's
called uh resistance at the threshold
and it's kind of like the same uh you
know the same
look of the painting and it has like the
same characters in it but it's 40 years
later
and then somebody else commissioned him
to make uh to do another one and that
was called threshold of revelation and
he painted that one in 2012. so he still
has a website as far as i know and then
somebody uh
else it might have been the same person
but there was like a third commission so
see he knew what he was doing he's
getting like a bunch of commissions out
of this [ __ ] somebody said hey paint a
prequel now so he's doing like a whole
[ __ ] expanded universe so he did he
did a prequel painting called the hands
invent him
uh and you know so that kind of went
uh there too so then in 2017
there's a the haunted museum in las
vegas
uh actually bought the prequel painting
so you can see it there in las vegas i
guess you can still see it there now the
other paintings i'm not sure where they
are you can see like the pictures of
them on his website
but uh apparently the dude's still
around and he actually painted uh
another
painting in the series in 2021 which is
called what remains and it has uh the
same
layout but everything looks like uh i
don't know if it's like post-apocalyptic
but it's like everything's gone you know
what i mean so he's done like
not too bad i mean he just painted it
back in the 70s and then for some reason
everybody like freaked out about it and
he was probably like whoa i got like all
these commissions i'm gonna cash in all
that [ __ ] like i said i don't blame them
not one bit
[ __ ] dumb people says larry um yeah
larry was saying maybe james needs cars
in one of those underground parking lots
with all the other cars yeah yeah it's
good no it's not though
james dean's car was
picked up
and taken to a local [ __ ] lot where
it probably sat for a couple days
a couple weeks and then sent to a local
scrap yard
in those days people were not really
cognizant of the idea of a collector's
market
dean was
dean was famous but the car wasn't
famous
they just weren't like that they would
uh get rid of this thing
if the family didn't claim it collect it
nobody wanted it didn't want to claim it
and pick it up and nobody really watered
it they just
it was a porsche spider
i imagine it probably got cannibalized a
little bit before they threw it away
took things off the [ __ ] engine like
took carbs off
took things here and there off of it if
any of that survived and sold it on a
[ __ ] black market or secondary market
but the car was just not special in its
day and sent to the scrap yard and
melted down it's gone
unfortunate it was a hot car it was hot
car
ben frail says cheeto that looks like
william h macy well yeah like some
people because again i i kind of feel
like ghosts in a jar was a thing and
there was also the whole remember that
really famous um
was it jesus or the virgin mary on the
toasted cheese sandwich
that somebody sold on ebay uh
jesus i think yeah it wasn't i can't
remember and somebody sold it somebody
sold it like in one of those little like
tupperware containers what they sell it
for like three grand or some [ __ ] like
that
and then of course everybody tried to do
it and honestly back there somewhere
i have somebody gave me for a present
it's pretty awesome i have a little
thing it's like a little bread shaped
thing and you push it into your bread
and then toast the bread and it puts
jesus on your bread yeah so i have one
of those so i could make
i could make lots and lots of those but
i don't think anybody paid for them
nowadays
larry says he agrees with me he's just
joking that car is gone that car is
[ __ ] gone it's too bad
too bad if you had james dean's [ __ ]
spider
you'd be a wealthy man if you could
prove it well they know the serial
numbers
and a pro could go in there and look at
that twisted wreck and go yeah that's it
but why haven't you sold this earlier
that would be the big question we've
been looking for this for [ __ ]
40 years why why now you know
where's this [ __ ] band
a lot of people have been looking for
that car
yeah you get a million at least i would
think for that car
yeah probably yeah i think so
yeah hugo says lol jesus on toast it is
delightful i mean i really like but i
think my friend liz gave it to me like
years ago and i've used it a few times
all you yeah you just like it's you know
it looks like a cookie cutter kind of
but you just like push it into the bread
before you toast it and then you toast
it and when it comes out it looks like
jesus on there it's pretty rad
but uh yeah so i can make like lots and
lots of them
um mr roboto says do they make the
spider now
well they make a lot of spiders it's
just the porsche spider at the time no
they don't make that anymore i'm gonna
go to the bathroom of course the spider
in a way when you looked at it was kind
of like a glorified karma gear
it had a lot of lot in common with that
um
it was it was a
a real cool car i saw one porsche spider
here in florida this is a couple years
back went riding and [ __ ] went riding
on [ __ ] the buell
and uh stopped off at a
uh starbucks and was sitting there
drinking and drinking coffee and uh car
came in and you could hear them damn
valves [ __ ] rapping and a
porsche spider pulled in
i walked right up to dude you know it's
like dude this [ __ ] car is awesome
he's like thank you thank you [ __ ]
and he was just an old
yuppie from the new york area who had a
house here and he had a because you have
to understand something here in florida
all the rich people from florida and
california have
have homes here
uh they [ __ ] you all states up
where they are but then they come over
here and this is this is
this is where they play you know they
keep it good here you've been seeing it
recently she's in the bathroom so i'm
gonna tell you
no okay the ruling class [ __ ] shows
up here while they [ __ ] up the rest of
the world and he was in that damn
porsche spider
we talked about it for hours and uh
you know the car was [ __ ] sweet it
was super sweet
and uh i didn't ask him who he was he
was probably somebody famous you know uh
but we talked about
cars and motorcycles and he was telling
me about the engine he had guys working
on it he didn't know everything about
internal combustion or anything but
the
there it was an air-cooled car and he
was like you know when it's hot weather
out here you know i think it makes a lot
of noise and i was like
put a little bit of uh two-stroke
two-stroke oil in the in the gasoline
uh maybe like from red line redline
redline burns really [ __ ] clean
and if you put that in any high
performance
push rod operated [ __ ] air-cooled
engine it it'll [ __ ] quiet down the
valve train a lot
uh because they those old push rod
operated [ __ ]
air-cooled
two-valve engines were made for old
gasoline they had a lot of [ __ ]
impurities in it
from back in the day
and the impurities and the oil inside
that gasoline kind of acted as a
lubricant for the valve train which made
it a lot quieter
a couple months later that same dude
pulled in together and he was like
[ __ ] giving me the thumbs up and he
says man i put some of that redline
[ __ ]
uh two-stroke oil in the engine and it
he's like it quieted it right down this
[ __ ] and i was like yeah yeah but i
don't really know who the guy was it's
kind of imply impolite to ask somebody
what they do for a living or who they
were
for all i know dude is a billionaire
but they have them around here come to
the restroom
poor start down says that danish that
looked like mother teresa was uncanny
i kind of feel like maybe well the
person as far as i know it wasn't a
person
that bought the um virgin mary or jesus
grilled cheese sandwich like the famous
one
i think it was um like one of those
kitschy museums in vegas because and
they just bought it because it was
really famous so i guess for them like
three thousand dollars wasn't that big a
deal because they figured like people
would come to see it because it was
famous so it wasn't just like some dumb
some dumbass from like nebraska or
something to be like it's jesus on a
grilled cheese sandwich take all my
money uh yeah it was it was actually
like a kitschy museum that uh that
bought it as far as i can remember i
don't know about the other stuff like
you know
the dorito that looked like bob hope or
whatever it's just kind of like you know
it's it's all that kind of stuff
uh all right so i had a couple other
paintings i want to talk about this one
there's not a lot about this one but
this is a pretty famous
image let me see if i can find it i have
it here somewhere oh there it is uh this
is a painting called the anguished man
now uh i kind of feel like there's a lot
of memes and kind of like stories about
this one but there's not a lot of info
on it they're not even really sure who
it was that painted it like they don't
know uh you know who the artist was
um but a person a guy named sean
robinson owns it i don't know if he
painted it and just says i don't know
where it came from or whatever i mean
that seems like something i'm that
sounds like something i would do she's
like i don't know where this painting
came from i found it in a
coffin in an attic or something like
that so uh so what sean robinson says is
that uh he doesn't know who the artist
is he says he got the painting from his
grandmother
and his grandmother told him allegedly
that the person who painted it mixed his
own blood into the paint just like in
the h.g lewis movie color me blood red
although that was kind of well he
started out with his own blood then he
started using other people's blood but
uh yeah so he mixed his own blood in the
paint and then after he finished the
painting he supposedly killed himself
and uh the painting has uh had you know
all this kind of stories about it being
cursed since then
uh apparently sean robin said i don't
know if it's still there but he did have
a youtube channel for a time and he did
do like some video recordings of the
painting and like talking about it and
stuff like that hold on larry said some
funny [ __ ] tom's gonna have a bunch of
dumb people putting two-stroke oil in
their motors yeah yeah
thank you larry
you put two-stroke oil in your engine
only if you have an air-cooled two-valve
push-rod operated motor all right
exactly
which those don't exist anymore no car
is like that we're talking about classic
old-school [ __ ]
from a time when gasoline had lead in it
all right and a lot of oil in in the
[ __ ] gasoline it was just a very it
was a different [ __ ] era
we're talking about
1950s and and before
we're talking about okay thank you larry
you're right you're right you're right
yeah
mary says what about the dress that was
like white to some people in blue to
others yeah i don't know if that was so
much curse that was just like a weird
like optical illusion i kind of remember
but i can't remember what color it
looked like to me i think it looked like
white to me but i'm not really sure
dj maniac says i have a friend named
vincent castilla that paints with his
own blood he just opened a tattoo shop
in florida yeah i kind of feel like
that's probably pretty common nowadays
like i said we just i was thinking about
herschel gordon-lewis because we did we
recorded a review of uh 2000 maniacs
like earlier today and uh he did a movie
called caller new blood red that was
about that about an artist that painted
with blood
uh you know when back in the 60s when
that was maybe like a big deal
so uh so yeah so here's another curse
painting this little painting here now
this is interesting because there's a
lot of different versions of this one
but this seems to be like the main
version of this one and it's called the
crying boy and this is what it looks
like
look at how sad that little kid is oh my
god he's making a little sad poopy face
so it's this painting there are other
variations of it because i guess this is
um
i guess that's a thing i do kind of feel
like maybe in the 70s
people wanted paintings of like sad
crying children in their houses for
whatever reason i don't really know but
that particular painting um
well why in the 1800s do they want naked
children in their [ __ ] houses because
they were perverts
that was that was an easy question
that's less explicable to me like naked
children like you know obviously they
were weird perverts that's why i think
they were yeah but you know crying
children i don't know that seems a
little strange
but uh that painting was done by an
italian painter named giovanni bragolin
bragolin and that's not his real name
that's like a pseudonym
and this painting for whatever reason
got like super famous if they like mass
produce like all these prints of it and
apparently like a [ __ ] ton of people
particularly in the uk
had this painting like on their wall
um and as i said there were multiple
variations it weren't always little boys
sometimes it was little girls too but it
was always like a really really sad
looking kid
like with little tears running down
their face like i said why i don't know
why you want their house but okay but i
mean i got
i can't judge i got all kind of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] in my house so you know
uh but yeah so this painting supposedly
also has a curse on it and the weird
thing this seems to have been mostly
fueled by the british tabloid media
back in 1985 because like i said i kind
of feel like this is a 70s thing that a
lot of old british people had in their
house this
painting back in 1985 the sun
in the uk
they did this story
that this firefighter in essex
apparently
said that he had been to just so many
fires you guys
that they found this painting at and the
painting
even though the house had like burned
down that that painting was always like
untouched
and he thought that it happened often
enough and he was weirded out enough by
it
apparently to like report it to a
tabloid newspaper
although like i said they could have
just made it up because i think the sun
does that too but
yeah so this firefighter said yeah we
found so many like of these paint and
they're always and they're never burned
and so
the uh the newspaper kind of obviously i
guess they got you know their readers
all like
you know uh upset about it like it was a
curse and everything and i think the
newspaper even later on they organized
like
like public burnings of the painting to
see if they would burn because the
you know the the urban legend started to
spread that this painting was cursed and
that you couldn't burn it so that it was
like i don't know possessed by demons or
some [ __ ] like that i don't know it was
the 80s [ __ ] satanic panic [ __ ] was
probably going on
but yeah so they did like mass bonfires
and stuff
so
later on
they had this other british like this
british comedian and he decided he was
gonna like look into this [ __ ]
and uh they did a thing like on bbc
radio 4 like he did a show about it
and he said that from his research that
if the stories about this painting
always turning up in you know fire
ravaged homes and like being untouched
are true
he said everybody he consulted said well
probably that's because maybe uh the
varnish that's on the painting
is like some kind of fire retardant
and
so when the painting is hanging on the
wall like the fire would burn the you
know the um the thing that was holding
the string whatever the [ __ ] the string
or the wire that was holding the
painting to the wall and then the
painting would fall off and like fall
face first but because it had fire
returning on it it wouldn't burn even
though everything around it would
so they were like that's pretty much all
they could come up with but
i don't know why just because it didn't
burn in fires often enough that people
noticed it like everybody started to
think the painting was cursed so i
thought that was kind of like [ __ ]
funny all right so let's talk about some
cursed dolls now like i said we're not
going to talk about annabelle because
everybody knows about annabelle and i
think we talked about that before anyway
on one of our uh
the warren's show i think we talked
about that and i think we've also talked
about robert the doll from key west
uh so i don't so i don't want to cover
that again because i'm pretty sure we
already talked about that but i found a
couple of other ones that we hadn't
talked about before one of these being
letta the gypsy doll also known as letta
me out
which uh you'll know why in a second
story goes that this doll which actually
i have a picture of this too i think
where is it where is it where is it
there's there she is
creepy right
it's creepy yeah
why did they make like ugly dolls that's
a female that's not a female doll
i don't know what it is that's a male
face with hair on it i don't know what
it is they're [ __ ] with you that's
they're trolling us
well you know i'm just saying i'm saying
so story goes that this house
uh this house this doll was found under
a house
in uh
wagga wagga australia oh australia never
change
um
this and again the story goes i don't
know if it was really found underneath
the house but okay that's that's the
story so the history of this doll
supposedly
was that a romanian gypsy made this doll
by hand because of course of course
uh and made it for their son whose name
was letta
now the boy
supposedly
told his dad that the doll talked to him
again creepy
now apparently this little boy
was playing with the doll one day and he
drowned
and so it's believed that the boys
ghost
is now trapped inside the doll
okay it's kind of like some chucky
action going on there
so this supposedly happened like almost
50 years ago right
now the guy that owns it now who's a
dude named carrie walton and he's
supposedly the one that found it under
the house
now he was the one that started calling
it let him me out because
i don't know how he knew about the
[ __ ] story about the kid named letter
or whatever
um
he says he brought the doll home
and he says that his kids
uh would wake up in the middle of night
and they were crying and they said the
doll was talking to them and moving its
head around okay and they were freaked
out
so other people that know this dude said
yeah when they've touched the doll or
stood by it um it makes them feel
uh what one website called irrational
grief
so they feel like super super bummed out
oh yeah
and then they start crying and stuff
without any reason for it so
it's has like some kind of weird
hormonal effect i guess yeah maybe
that's why it has it has hormones on it
uh so yeah so the the doll's wood okay
and it has human hair on it which you
know creepy
um yeah so a bunch of people have said
they've seen this doll like move around
uh if you bring a dog by it supposedly
uh the dog will try to eat it because
the dog doesn't like it
and so
so the guy uh carrie walton who owns it
of course um like i said this sounds
like another story he takes the doll
around australia and like puts it on
display
um and he says that every time he takes
the doll out like i said that's why they
call it letting me out every time he
takes the doll out it rains
so
the doll is like bumming everyone out
and making it rain all the time
and talking to your kids and like moving
around by itself so there you go i mean
it is a creepy looking doll i will say i
don't actually know where this doll came
from i don't buy that
romanian gypsy story not one bit
um but like i said it's a good so if you
come up with a good story like that and
it goes [ __ ] viral
you know
i wonder how many artists have done that
have painted something or made a doll or
something and then instead of saying
they did it they just came forward and
said i don't have any idea like i just
found this painting in the attic of this
abandoned house i was in
and
you know now it's like i hear it
whispering at night and all this other
kind of stuff and now i have an idea
uh all right so
uh another haunted doll that we're going
to talk about is mandy the doll now this
doll is supposedly 114 years old again
this doll is pretty creepy to look at i
think i have a picture of her somewhere
where is she there she is i mean you
know
why
hello
i love it i love it why would they make
[ __ ] creepy ass dolls like that back
in the old days murder hornets nessie
show me so i'll send it next week that's
the ipad that's the eye franchise
i thought he was making it up
we'll see that's kind of a funny-looking
eye patch i have to see that in person
before if i could wear that
it looks kind of like something you put
over a nipple
that works too yeah you could just put
it over this and put it under your
armpit or whatever just put it over one
andrea smith said the doll identifies as
a female
yeah um let me see oh mary says i got a
walking doll that my mom put my old
clothes on her ah that's a little creepy
i ate some peanut butter toast and had a
butter knife i dreamed it got up coming
at me i made her get rid of it honestly
i don't blame you i don't know why
i mean and i i kind of feel like back in
the victorians were weird okay and it's
like the victorians i kind of feel like
we're notorious
for making like the world's creepiest
looking [ __ ] dolls you know it's like
why it's just i don't know so so creepy
because i kind of feel like this doll if
it really is 114 years old that's yeah
that's about victorian
esque era maybe a little bit later um so
this doll
known as canada's most evil antique
made i don't know how much competition
there is in that area so 1991 this doll
got donated to this museum in british
columbia
and uh so apparently like a lot of
people go there and see her i don't know
about nowadays if the museum's still
open but it was uh whenever this article
that i'm sourcing from uh was written
now apparently the person that had owned
this doll originally the person that uh
donated her to the museum
um
didn't really like the doll she said it
made her feel really weird and she was
creeped out by it so she actually kept
it in the basement
uh with a bunch of other antiques and
started hearing like a bunch of weird
sounds coming from the basement as soon
as you put the doll down there and then
she would go down to the basement and
see what the [ __ ] the noise was and then
couldn't find anything
um so then after a while like weird
noises kind of graduated to a baby
crying sound of a baby crying coming
from this room
and again she keeps going in there and
never did find anything
so i guess that after a while uh this
noise was just getting worse and worse
and then she eventually ended up
associating it with this mandy doll
and uh said well this doll is obviously
like [ __ ] haunted
so uh she didn't really want to throw it
away because who knows what would happen
then but uh so she ended up donating it
to the museum and apparently like the
haunting or whatever it was like stopped
at her house after but then it started
up at the museum that the doll got uh
you know got uh given to
so
one thing this is hilarious to me like
this this one article i love
it's creepy enough that people look like
oh the doll moves around by itself and
and talks and [ __ ] like that okay that's
creepy
but here's one thing that mandy
apparently does that just is kind of
like funny
so apparently it's like not long after
mandy the doll came to this museum
people who worked in the museum started
complaining
that their lunches
were vanishing out of the refrigerator
and were turning up like stuffed into
random drawers
around the building
i'm like
seems like a little bit petty for like a
haunted doll to be doing that kind of
[ __ ] that just sounds like some [ __ ]
that works there like
stealing food out of the refrigerator
and then stuffing it in drawers
somewhere but yeah so they said that was
there was like an epidemic of that after
the doll came
um
a lot of employees at the museum said
that a bunch of their their stuff like
from their desks would like disappear
and they'd never find it again um they
said at first that they put mandy in
this case near the entrance
but people started complaining about it
it's like we walk in the museum and like
we don't feel good like it was making
him feel weird and [ __ ] so they had to
like move it
and she was apparently first put into a
case with a bunch of other dolls
but
mandy apparently wanted all the
spotlight to herself she did not really
like all these other dolls being in the
case so they would wait you know they
would come into work and they'd find
like the other dolls in the case were
like kind of [ __ ] up they were all
like damaged so
they had to put mandy like in her own
case
uh so she they stick her in a case in
the corner
now after uh you know this kind of story
the curse got around so there was a book
that came out uh called supernatural
stories around british columbia and it
talked about mandy the doll in there so
after that book came out you know she
got a lot more famous so a lot of people
started coming to the museum just to see
her
and uh you know pretty much around the
doll people um started reporting kind of
your regular like paranormal kind of
stuff like you know your phone batteries
are you know drain really fast or your
camera doesn't work
um there's a lot of people have taken
pictures of her and said the pictures
didn't come out like they were all
blurry or there was like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
like light or whatever in front of them
um and some people uh said that the
doll like heads move and like watches
them as they're walking around the room
and that they see her eyes blink uh you
know like out of the corner of their
eyes [ __ ] like that and uh she seems to
like move around in the case as well uh
so yeah that's uh mandy the doll now
this
story right here this isn't exactly a
curse doll but i just thought this was
so [ __ ] funny that i had to mention
it this is one thing it kept coming up
when i was talking about like haunted
dolls
and even though there's kind of like
this is apparently true but i guess
there is
a real explanation for it but it's still
like funny as [ __ ]
so this is uh the death threat elmo
okay okay so back in 2008
uh you know you know elmo the the
lovable sesame street
uh so there was a line of elmo dolls
which was called elmo knows your name
which kind of sounds like a threat but
okay that's what the dolphin says
that's what the doll was called and it
apparently had this kind of like chip in
it that you could like teach it your
name and it would talk to you and like
say your name you know what i mean like
hey whatever your name is blah blah blah
i'm elmo you know let's brush our teeth
or whatever the [ __ ] i don't know what
he said
uh
but
apparently there was some kind of glitch
with this one particular one and it was
a family in lithia florida
the bowman family
and apparently they bought their son
james who i think was two
they bought him an elmo knows your name
doll
and the doll started saying in his
little elmo voice kill james kill james
like over and over again
and um the mom was understandably
unnerved by the situation
um so again apparently this is a real
story because i did look it up and i was
just kind of like that sounds like some
[ __ ] or like some [ __ ] but no it is
a real thing uh they did actually
determine
the uh the dolls i guess the um
the battery was dying or whatever and it
was kind of like glitching out
so
it just it got his name which was james
which he told the name but it and then
it just started like saying something
that sounded like kill james you know
what i mean so they did actually like
give them a replacement
but it got it went like all over the
internet like the [ __ ]
and of course like all the articles are
super hilarious because like [ __ ]
i i just thought it was funny that one
of them called them like [ __ ] death
threat elmo so elma's gonna like
threaten to kill your kid and [ __ ] can
you imagine the [ __ ] elmo i just
thought that was so [ __ ] funny
holy [ __ ] all right okay where are we
now murder hornet return says it's real
came right off a guy with one eye okay
dj maniac says elmo knows where you live
i can't believe they called it elmo
knows your name the doll
that sounds i mean that's kind of
sinister sounding not to a little kid
i don't know i think it's kind of i
think it's sinister i'm like i don't
want elmo knowing my name goddamn
little kid will want elmo to know what
they're doing
oh yeah i know your name too elmo
yeah i love you elmo
that's how little kids are you know
i always kind of liked elmo i know a lot
of people think he's annoying but
i thought he was kind of cute i used to
have
elbow knows where you live
cheryl said elmo's creepy anyways yeah
he is a little bit yeah um cheryl been
catching the [ __ ] show regularly yeah
yeah thank you for [ __ ] joining us
cheryl we i recognize i recognize
i used to have this toy when i was
younger i can't remember what the hell
what the hell was the name of this line
they don't make them anymore yeah it
wasn't like a um
you know like a known character or
anything it wasn't tribbles it wasn't i
don't know what it was but it was just
like this little
dude he was like a little creature
he didn't look like it was kind of
looked like a bear sort of but like he
didn't have any ears and he was wearing
like a little
uh like a little hooded cloak it was
purple
it sounds like a [ __ ] ewok
he didn't look no it didn't look like an
ewok um he did he wasn't as complicated
as that his his face was just he was
kind of beige and then like his face was
just i don't even think he had a nose or
a mouth did he just have eyes i don't
know i still have it somewhere so i have
to like go find it but he had like a
little purple cloak on i think they had
ones that had different colored cloaks
on them like they had one with a teal
one and a red one and stuff and he his
little eyes
like he made a little uh giggling i was
like
like a little giggly noise and his like
eyes would flash
i have it somewhere
that was those little gnome things
they're like little gnomes right is he
like
it was 80s i think it was early 80s that
i had it okay
what the hell was it called it was
like
something it had a name that sounded
like ible it's not tribbles obviously
but it was something that sounded like
that
and he made like a
it didn't sound like a human laugh it
sounded kind of like a weird like little
i don't know it was like a weird giggly
noise but yeah i had one i might still
have it somewhere
thank you for joining us on the show
[ __ ] jenny's been put doing a good
show tonight if i can um
i'm loaded i can barely talk and right
now really
i'm passing around the collection plate
i'm gonna send jenny a super chat for
her hard work thank you very much okay
go ahead oh thank you i appreciate thank
you very much yeah
use them super chats
she gets all the money anyway
oh he's trying to start something
hey i buy you some [ __ ] sometimes it's
all right it's it's just normal life and
i pay we all we all take care of this
[ __ ] yeah tomorrow i gotta go down and
[ __ ] close this [ __ ] house
that's right nothing but [ __ ] two
hours of signing paperwork the house is
done i remember doing that back then i
can tear that and take that stupid-ass
chandelier out of that [ __ ] dining
room and then i'm gonna start painting
this place on the inside
yeah we're gonna have to decide on the
paint and i gotta pull them [ __ ]
plants out the front of this house and
if i can reroute that damn entryway
yeah that'll be nice yeah
yeah as soon as you've signed all the
[ __ ] like you can see the places are so
i'm [ __ ] tearing this place up
it's tearing this place up some of this
just [ __ ] wrong
i mean i mean there's a lot of [ __ ] that
i want to do with the house but i don't
really have the money to do it but i
mean paint and chill it's not that
expensive yeah yeah yeah little by
little i mean i just bought the paint
that i bought for this room i painted
this room in the bathroom that's all
that i've painted so far and that paint
was like 70. she just got her bathroom i
got my bathroom up there that my
bathroom up there i don't like the color
of that bathroom though i don't like the
color of it
we're gonna do our bedroom and then the
[ __ ] the gym and my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] uh [ __ ] around room i'm gonna
have that one it's [ __ ] around around
um i'm gonna do a show from that room
once that's done
yeah i'm gonna do my own show from that
room but it's gonna be uh survivalist
type stuff and paramilitary stuff and
then once that's done i'm gonna paint
that [ __ ] living room and then i'm
gonna move downstairs we're gonna we'll
do room by room
that front entry way i'm thinking about
putting a fake tuscan
[ __ ] um outside bricks paint that
into the wall because doesn't that look
like something that actually should be
outside between two buildings
like a like a uh like an italian
this house looks italian from the inside
i'm gonna
that looks like that should be
a [ __ ]
a bistro down there
i kind of like that idea right actually
i like that idea put a bar down there
light it up put some tables like it's
like it's outside because downstairs
looks like outside it does it's between
two buildings well because the entryway
which i guess is tall
it's yeah it's tall it's all the way up
to the second floor like the ceiling and
then there's like this that should be
bricks and then it's like then there's
like a like an arched window
above the door and stuff and those
columns looks like they should be bricks
like somewhere out [ __ ] a tuscany
that might look nice actually it should
look like an italian
i mean the front room which i guess yeah
i mean it's supposed to be kind of like
you're like a little living room like a
little foyer and then like maybe a
formal dining room yes but we don't
really like use a formal dining room for
anything because there's like a there's
like a little dining room in the kitchen
off the kitchen area i want this [ __ ]
to look like an amusement park it
already looks it already looks like a
nightclub upstairs it does yeah yeah i'm
gonna put video games out it's gonna
look better when we get some furniture
yeah because we don't have much
furniture i can't really [ __ ] this house
up because i don't own it once i own it
but after tomorrow yeah once we own it
i'll i'll do something with it oh look
super chats thank you bryce i'm asking
for super chat just joined hope i didn't
miss out on too many cursed objects
still we still got some no i i got some
diamonds and some all kind of fun stuff
so i'm a little over halfway through but
that's 10 new zealand dollars thank you
very much man thank you awesome yeah
everybody says congratulations on the
house yeah yeah yeah so you're gonna be
uh gotta sign up for tomorrow it's done
yeah they'll give you a big pile of
paperwork and here's the thing man i
gotta pay the old [ __ ] tax rate this
year 12 months from now we're going to
save 300 a month just in taxes
that's when i'll be able to but it
worked out that the
[Music]
mortgage payment yeah is pretty much the
same as our rent as the rent was yeah it
didn't go up so it didn't it
was nice
the va helped me out because they went
in there and went nah it's not worth
[ __ ] 475 it's worth 460. yeah the
sellers were asking for and the seller
almost backed out yeah my old landlord
but then the broker that i was using
says what are you doing you're already
owed me [ __ ] five thousand the broker
said you owe me five thousand in
commission
whether this goes through or not yeah so
you're going to be putting it back up on
the market and waiting and who knows how
long you're going
next year and a half or two years just
go ahead and take it now so
that broker and that broker's asking me
says if you want to buy another [ __ ]
property i can get you
something for 185 000 with your credit
and i'm thinking about
buying a bar
in this area yeah
that's what i'm thinking about people
buying a buying a road house bar for 185
000 something around that i mean it'd
have to be like that but that scuzzy
biker bar you hang out yeah they want to
sell that and i could might be able to
buy that but the thing is they're gonna
cheat they're gonna change that road
there yeah it'll be right up against it
i think i can find something better you
probably could
and maybe me and tom me and big tom will
go in and buy something
big tom's my buddy who owns
yeah and [ __ ] he wanted me to go in
on this on mannequins with him in terms
but
i'm gonna have it too bad big tom wants
us to do the show from the [ __ ] his
club and i'm like we don't really well
he's asked us so many times and i'm just
like nobody's going to be able to hear
what we're saying though because it's so
loud yeah
big time my partner [ __ ] big time a
little top
there's a big black one and a little
white one
i'm army and he's ex-navy it's a big
black hoodie yeah big black and a little
white one we're working together good
[ __ ] um we i'm thinking about [ __ ] we
gotta buy i gotta i think if they can
get me another hundred and eighty five
thousand i need to buy something
once this shit's closed and once it's
rolling not this year but next year i
mean something that makes money i don't
think either something that you can rent
out or a business that is already making
money sure
i'm going to make money but it's going
to take another year
i think yeah
yeah go to the restroom all right
all right so let's talk about
the hope diamond now i was actually
going to do a whole show about this but
then when you know cursed objects went i
was like i might as well throw the hope
diamond in there you know what i mean uh
cheryl says tom's bar for sexual
policemen
oh my god that's what he should call it
the sexual policeman that'd be so
[ __ ] funny i'm gonna have to tell him
that when he comes back uh alright so
let's talk about the hope diamond now uh
hope diamond uh not the only
supposedly cursed diamond and or even
the cursed gem but i feel like diamonds
for whatever reason there's always any
kind of like famous diamond always has
like some kind of curse attached to it
for whatever reason like i said it's
it's just very very common
and uh usually anybody that owns them or
when he's you know they're supposed to
like have all this cause all this bad
luck and [ __ ]
so the hope diamond probably the most
famous diamond in the world uh it's in
the smithsonian in washington dc i've
actually seen it it's beautiful um you
know i've seen it in person so that's so
i thought that was pretty cool i didn't
have anything bad happen to me so i'm
just saying that um so it's a blue
diamond uh 45 carats
about the size of a walnut
uh they think that maybe
at least according to this article that
i uh that i'm sourcing from
uh
probably worth about a quarter of a
billion dollars i mean it is a big ass
diamond as diamonds go
so
the origin of this story and whether
this is true or not because i kind of
feel like every cursed diamond or gem
always has the backstory
that
this
you know xyz gem was in the forehead of
some idol in india somewhere
some thief went and plucked it out and
then they got killed and now it's passed
from hand to hand and you know everybody
everybody that owned it like suffered a
horrible fate in blahdy blah and this
one is like no different
uh the hope diamond supposedly
was in the forehead of an indian temple
idol and then got plucked out by a hindu
priest
uh who
died in an apparently horrible way not
too long after that
uh so then later on it gets found in the
golconda mines uh in southwest india
cheryl says this tom's bar for sexual
police that's what i said i said i have
to tell you i said well you should call
your brother sexual policeman yeah she
must be [ __ ] following my instagram
doing the sexual policeman [ __ ] video
photos i'm gonna have to [ __ ] make it
make a make a video of me as the sexual
policeman i'll [ __ ] post that [ __ ] up
on [ __ ] youtube on [ __ ] uh
instagram i just haven't you gotta take
it though okay i'm gonna i'm gonna be in
my [ __ ] my blacks put on a cop outfit
okay i i just pictured it boots my black
my silky black [ __ ] booty shorts
[ __ ] outta get me my [ __ ] eye patch
your eye yeah you need that eye patch
fake mustache fake mustache
uh [ __ ] little mini vest
i feel like you also you need a night
stick nice stick you need a nightstand
yeah i got a stick i got a nice day this
is the stick for any kind of time
for the night or day i'll dance around
and you could do the video and
everything the music and everything
it'll be funny you edit that [ __ ]
you're gonna read it ready to edit it
yeah okay i'll do it we'll put that [ __ ]
up on instagram we'll drop it we'll drop
it in the data stream of the show
i just kind of feel like sexual
policeman
i'm enforcing the sexual laws
[ __ ] better be [ __ ] i better be
[ __ ] if y'all ain't [ __ ] then
you're in violence i'm just picturing
that grandpa is giving me a badge and
everything grav is gonna give me his old
badge
okay
i'm picturing how this video would go
honestly how funny would it be
you just you just in your booty shorts
and a badge and a mustache with a night
stick and i'm just picturing you like
sticking your butt into the camera and
then turning around and going
with a night
stick like very suggestive like you're
going to see this like you're going to
stick this nightstick
[Laughter]
all right all right all right you settle
down
oscar says what about the haunted chair
the one they have mounted this uh by the
ceiling at the museum so nobody can sit
on it i am gonna talk about that i
promise i will get to that
it's like the second to last story uh so
yeah so hope diamond uh so they find it
in this uh mine in southwest india
and it makes its way to europe uh 1642
it gets bought by a french merchant
who sold it to
king louis xiv
now apparently this merchant that sold
it to king louis before says i'm
breaking the law i'm not breaking the
law i'm enforcing the law okay i'm gonna
say i'm a policeman i'm enforcing the
law okay sorry sorry sorry
sorry for interrupting
i'm not breaking i mean he just he gets
excited i get excited
slasher fred says james dean's car is
supposed to be cursed yeah we we had
that we had that disgusting we had that
that car is gone you'll never had that
discussion
um but yes like a while back yeah
but yeah so uh okay so the merchant that
supposedly sold it to king louis xiv
uh got killed by a pack of wild dogs you
know as one does
now uh the hope diamond was uh stayed in
the french royal family
in 1792 it was stolen during the french
revolution
now famously uh this is again attributed
to the hope diamond curse louis xiv and
marie antoinette obviously both got
their heads chopped off on the
guillotine and so a lot of people have
attributed that to them having owned the
hope diamond at some point
uh so after that the diamond kind of
like they're not really sure where it
was for a couple uh for like 20 years or
something
and during some time when it wasn't
really in the spotlight it got cut down
uh to a smaller size
uh they think maybe during this time
that it maybe belonged to king george iv
of britain uh and then got sold because
the dude went into a bunch of debt so
they sold it
uh so the next time that it turns up is
1839
uh they uh that was the guy that got it
was henry thomas hope which is where it
got its name
and after he died apparently nothing bad
happened to him but he um you know he
died and then it kind of went to a bunch
of different owners now
apparently everybody that's owned it
other than hope i don't know if anything
terrible happened to him but
um
apparently there's all kind of like [ __ ]
that happened like [ __ ] uh you know
everybody like people were murdered or
they committed suicide or they went poor
or whatever so like i said this is kind
of what we were talking about earlier
with like you know king tut's curse and
[ __ ] like that if you
if you're like expanding the misfortune
from just like creepy deaths to just
general
bad [ __ ] happening like oh you went
broke or
you know you've
you've stubbed your toe or whatever the
hell uh then obviously the curse is
going to seem a lot more a lot worse
than it is because bad [ __ ] happens to
everybody so you know but
so you didn't necessarily have to get
your head chopped off
to have
been considered to be like a victim of
the curse you just had to lose all your
money or something like or go crazy or
get addicted to heroin or whatever the
hell
so
as i said there's there's like [ __ ] tons
of different like curse diamonds hope
diamonds are the the most famous but
there's always kind of like
and i guess what it is
is
mostly who ends up owning these diamonds
or these gems or whatever though
they're obviously usually it's going to
be royal families or very very rich
people who are kind of like um
you know i guess more like in the public
eye or whatever so if something bad
happens to them
or their extended family then people are
gonna hear about it
it's just some
joe schmoe owned this massive [ __ ]
diamond who nobody knew him from adam
um if some bad [ __ ] happened to him no
one would hear about it because he's not
like famous or rich or anything you know
what i'm saying
yeah so i kind of feel like
all of these gems that are supposedly
cursed yeah if you go far enough back
into you know the french royal family
the british royal family whatever um you
know you're gonna find
bad [ __ ] happening to people because
that's just what i don't know is you
know and they're well known so it's just
gonna get more heard about
is all i'm saying uh so basically uh
let's be honest what some no-name
[ __ ] never gonna get his hands
on some gem that size well yeah that's
what i'm saying so uh so the fact that
you have the money
to have a gem
yeah which the diamond like i said is
like a quarter of a billion dollar yeah
i've seen it in real life it's big
yeah um you know what i mean it's it's
like that it's like that big which like
for a diamond that's like [ __ ] it's
beautiful but it's like it's huge if you
have that you're already gonna be one of
the kind of persons that they would
[ __ ] make a story about anyway
that's what i'm saying
so you know
these gems they they get this reputation
just
you know just by virtue of the fact that
it's not just some random [ __ ]
that owns it it's like somebody that's
in a royal family or somebody that's you
know a wealthy industrialist or
something you know what i'm saying
and obviously if something bad happens
in that family everybody's gonna hear
about it so so i think there's like a
statistical thing going on there too so
uh so basically what happens i think too
is that
because diamonds are so
um
you know in the public imagination or so
tied up with wealth and like you said
it's you know it has to be like a very
very wealthy family would own something
like this in the first place
and i think that there's some kind of
like the reason a lot of these stories
spring up about it is like a moralizing
thing
you know what i'm saying uh you know so
you own this this beautiful like really
expensive thing and you know so bad
shit's gonna happen to you so it's
almost kind of like a
a moral thing against greed i guess you
know so that's why these like stories
keep popping up
because interestingly the thing about
the hope diamond um is that yeah
everybody that owned it supposedly like
bad should happen to them
but
apparently
if you
are not greedy like if you don't sell
the diamond if you just give it away
then nothing bad will happen to you
that's the story because
uh the person the last person that owned
it was a was harry winston he was a
jeweler
and he actually donated it to the
smithsonian in 1958 and nothing bad
happened to him
so the story was going that well because
he just donated it and didn't get any
profit from it then the curse wasn't
effective which leads me to believe that
the whole story of the curse is kind of
like an anti-greed
morality tale is what it is
um but yeah so it's been in the
smithsonian collection since the 50s so
i don't know if you can still see it now
it's been like a while
it was probably like the mid-2000s and i
went to dc and i went to all the
smithsonian museums and i saw the hope
diamond there but it's sometimes it's
there sometimes it's not because they're
you know doing restorations or whatever
but
it's really cool to like see it in real
life though it's really cool looking
what's the time how long we've been
streaming uh two hours and 25 minutes
okay we're good yeah yeah we're good all
right
uh now there's i was going to talk about
the blue diamond but i think i'll skip
that because it's kind of like
it's kind of a similar story uh you know
all of the kind of there's a ton of
different curse gems you can look all
that [ __ ] up they're not all diamonds
either but almost all of the stories are
exactly the same which leads me to
believe that it's kind of like an urban
legend yeah you know the the gem was
stolen from the forehead of an indian
idol and then everybody in the you know
and then the person that stole it like
you know was eaten by dogs or whatever
alligators and then like it went to some
royal family and all kind of terrible
[ __ ] happened so they're all kind of
like that so let's talk very briefly
about
this is not an object necessarily but i
thought this was very interesting
because i didn't realize this was a
whole like subgenre of
cursed object stories
cursed phone numbers
i didn't realize this was the thing just
goes to show you learn something new
every day
so uh the first one that i want to talk
about is one and like a whole bunch of
zeros out of like nine zeros after it
now this was supposedly
vulnerable in asia it's very very famous
it's like the first one that comes up
every time like dude cursed phone number
so apparently if you call this phone
number
and you know don't do or you can do it
it's like you know but don't blame me
um if you call this number apparently a
male voice
will tell you
to tell 15 others about the number
now
this is supposedly like a dead person's
number or like um not a
not a singular dead person but just like
the dead in general this is like the
dead people phone number
uh so if you
get a call from it because apparently it
can send out calls as well
that means that you have a dead person
that's trying to get in contact with you
they're trying to call you from the
other side this is like the dead person
hotline apparently
uh now
also the shades of the ring right this
is kind of why because like i said this
is very popular in asia
so the dude on this call supposedly says
if you don't tell 15 people about this
phone number then you're gonna die
within a week again very much like the
ring so i kind of feel like maybe that's
where they came from
now this is the first one that i saw
this is a this is a phone number in
bulgaria and it's just zero with like
nine or ten eights after zero eight
eight eighty eight
now
this
number is uh actually supposedly a curse
number now
the first person that owned this mobile
number their the cell number
was a guy named vladimir granov i guess
now he was the ceo of the of the uh cell
phone company who was the carrier of the
phone number
so he got that phone number
and he ended up dying not too long after
he got this phone number from like a
super fast-acting cancer like he got
some really aggressive cancer
so then the number passed to the next
ceo that took over after him
of the company uh and his name was
constantine dimitrov
and he was shot to death in the street
the number then passed to a third person
i don't know if he was a ceo or not but
it was passed to a third person named
constantine
dischlieve
and that guy was also shot in the street
and i don't think they caught the person
the people that did it
so after these three incidents
apparently this cell phone company
decided they were going to retire this
phone number because they uh imagined
that it was cursed
so another curse phone number this one
based in marion north carolina uh the
number is eight two eight
seven five six zero one zero nine if
anybody wants to call it don't blame me
if you do
uh yeah marion north carolina about 85
miles from charlotte apparently when you
call this number you'll hear
um
kind of like creepy ass noises like you
hear a dude
um
giving you a message and what sounds
like binary code
and when you decode the binary uh it
spells death
this one works only in the u.s now some
of these phone numbers i will say
when you call them
you do actually hear the [ __ ] that is
described but some of them are
later found out to be like args or
uh some kind of like viral marketing for
a movie or something like that so
you know so so sometimes you do call
these numbers and you're like holy [ __ ]
like there's some creepy [ __ ] it sounds
like somebody's being murdered or
something like that but
it's not always what it appears to be
like i said because some of it is like
had to do with like args and whatnot
so there's this other phone number uh
408
two eight zero six
this was uh now i looked this up
actually it says located in or around
san martin california this landline
number is registered with an unknown
carrier now this
phone number
has to do with an urban legend this is
actually called the red room number
this number supposedly if you call it
um it tells the person at the other end
where you are and
if you call the number
then someone will come and kidnap you
and take you to a red room where you
will be tortured and killed and your
death will be streamed over the web
which sounds kind of like uh david
cronenberg's movie does it not it does
uh but yeah i haven't called that i
probably would not call it but i'm just
saying
it was interesting when i looked that
number up and it said this it's a
landline number but uh
it
it said registered with an unknown
carrier so i thought that was kind of
funny
um
stephen jeffries are you talking about
976 evil
we need to review that one day i put it
in the poll a couple times but it never
wins i haven't seen it in like [ __ ]
forever
i always like stephen jeffries man i
liked him from [ __ ] he was evil ed
and fright night you know i was into it
uh
murder corner return says i'll call now
say it again which one the red room
number or the
or the uh
the first one that the north carolina
one that just has like uh the binary
code spell and death was eight two eight
seven five six
zero one zero nine
and then the other one the red room one
that's supposedly you'll get kidnapped
and tortured or murdered on the on live
on a live stream is 408
634-2806 so i don't know
ben frail said there are some great
korean horror movies about phones name
escapes me i think there's one called
one missed call i think that's kind of
the most famous one
which actually is very good yeah they do
a lot of uh
asian horror like a lot of it has to do
with like uh technology gone bad
you know like the ring and
pulse that's actually a really good one
and i'm trying to think of like some
other ones but yeah one missed call i
remember that one
but yeah
there's yeah there's a lot of ones about
like people [ __ ] calling you and
being [ __ ] creepy and [ __ ]
all right so i think how many more do i
have uh
okay i just have like four more short
ones so tom will be happy about that
oh you coming back okay yeah i'm back is
it running yeah okay
we thought i wasn't coming back well i
don't know
you might have like you might have
passed out in there
he like fell asleep on the toilet or
some [ __ ] i don't know
uh so i said so i have like four more
like short
little uh short little things about
right which colors mice
okay so these are just kind of like
miscellaneous ones
so here's this one called the bassano
vase
now this vase uh or vaz if you prefer
is made of silver apparently made in the
15th century
story behind it uh it was given to a
bride
on the eve of her wedding so i guess
like a wedding present
but
she never did make it to the altar
because the night before she was
supposed to get married
she got murdered
and she was sitting there holding the
vase i don't know why she was holding
the vase but okay she got murdered like
the night before
so the vase gets passed down through her
family
and the story goes that anybody that had
the vase
uh died
not long after taking possession of it
so a whole bunch of people in her family
died uh the family said [ __ ] this [ __ ]
put it in a box and stuck it in an attic
somewhere
it turned up again in 1988
which again this sounds like a story
uh apparently
there's a note with it i'm assuming that
back in the day when the family packed
it up they put a note in it and said
beware this vase brings death
so you know
that's what the note said now they
auctioned the base off
but they didn't include the note which
kind of seems like they probably should
seems a little irresponsible not to but
okay so they put in the auction without
the note
uh so a guy buys it not knowing that the
shit's cursed and was dead within three
months
uh
three more
uh people who owned it subsequently also
supposedly died
uh but then
i guess it ended up like after the last
person died like it ended up going to
you know whoever liked the [ __ ]
estate agent or whatever like came and
took it now the story about this one i
guess the it's a vase but it has like a
lid on it
so i guess
as long as you leave the lid on oh
pokey's on the show yeah hi poke she's
like what am i doing up here i'm not on
the floor anymore look at her little
feet
she's like okay i'll i will lay
[Laughter]
she's like stop it stop it daddy
you're being so good
she looks kind of mad though i mean
maybe maybe not she just woke up oh okay
yeah oh she's cranky
no
but yeah so uh so yeah so apparently
while the lid is on this it supposedly
stays dormant but the story behind it is
that if you take the lid off
the vase starts
essentially like attracting people to it
that are like
murderers like serial killers and stuff
like they get lured in by the vase's
curse and then they'll kill the people
that own it that's how the story goes
anyway
so the next one i want to talk about is
the woman from limb this is a statue
and this was apparently uh found in lem
cyprus in 1878
uh supposedly about 3 000 years old it's
uh made of limestone
and they called it the woman of lem
because that's you know
the
the town where they found it uh which is
on cyprus
now
after i guess like it started getting a
reputation so they started calling it uh
the goddess of death it's supposed to be
like a fertility goddess or something
so the first guy that supposedly owned
this was a dude named lord elfant
elephant not like elephant but kind of
uh this was during the british colonial
occupation of cyprus
now
the lord elephant and six other members
of his family
uh supposedly all died within six years
of getting this statue
after that it traveled to another family
uh it got bought by a dude named ivor
monucci
and all of his family died within four
years of getting the statue
then the statue moves on to another guy
named lord thompson noel
that's fabulous
uh and all of his family also died
within a couple of years
of owning the statue
now apparently the last private buyer to
own this statue his wife and two
daughters and himself
died within a year
his sons survived though for whatever
reason
and they still had the statue
and they were afraid that the statue was
gonna kill them i mean you know
rightfully so
so they ended up donating it to uh the
royal museum in edinburgh in scotland
but uh apparently when the museum put
the statue on display
the curator
died
within a year of handling it
uh supposedly the this statue is still
in the museum at least as far as you
know whatever this article was which is
just a year or two ago and uh they keep
it in a really heavy glass display case
you're not supposed to touch it because
apparently it's gonna [ __ ] you up so all
right now we're gonna get to the chair
of death which a couple people have like
asked about this is that yeah this is a
pretty good story actually
so uh so there's a tavern uh pub
called the busby stoop inn
uh it's in a place called sand hutton in
north yorkshire
now this tavern is supposedly haunted
and the haunting seems to be caused by
what they call the chair of death
so this so this chair
uh was supposedly the favorite chair of
a convicted murderer named thomas busby
now 1702 old thomas
uh was on his way to the gallows
in thirsk england
he wanted to pop into his favorite pub
uh and get a drink of ale before he was
gonna get hanged or whatever
uh and he's so he wants to go in and get
a drink and sit in his favorite chair
now this guy had actually been convicted
he killed his father-in-law whose name
was daniel audi
now supposedly this was a very
chair-centric fella i'm gonna say
because supposedly he killed his
father-in-law
for sitting in his favorite chair and he
so he strangled him i mean you know as
one does i understand somebody sits in
your favorite chair yeah you're gonna
strangle a [ __ ] i see i don't
know if it was the actual chair
that people's claim is haunted nowadays
or if this was a totally different chair
it was like his lazy boy like in his
house i don't really know but he's just
like so supposedly he strangled his
father-in-law for sitting his favorite
chair
so he goes to the pub on the way to the
gallows because he's like hey you know
have a heart i'm gonna have a drink and
i'm gonna sit in my favorite chair for
one last time before i get hanged
and when he sat down in the chair just
to be
an [ __ ] just because he's trolling
he supposedly said may sudden death come
to anyone who dare sit in my chair he's
[ __ ] serious about this being his
favorite chair okay
uh so he goes to the gallows uh you know
as happens
now story starts going around
particularly during the second world war
um the pub kind of became like a popular
spot with you know uh you know
servicemen and stuff
so uh
what ended up happening was that
people that sat in the chair
and then went off into battle they would
always die and people started it
happened often enough i guess that
people were like noticing they're like
hey everybody that sits in that chair
they don't come back from the battle you
know what i mean
uh you know the story goes 1967 there
were two royal air force pilots who sat
in it and then while they were driving
back to the base
they crashed the car into a tree and
both died
and it wasn't just military people
either because apparently like some just
some uh you know local work men or
whatever
um a couple years after like in the
early 1970s apparently there were two uh
bricklayers and they said oh we're gonna
sit in the chair of death you know what
i mean so they sat down in the chair
and then later on that afternoon the one
who had sat in it uh fell off a roof and
died so there was that
uh so this chair
they call it they don't call it chair of
death for nothing supposedly
everybody that sits in it
it kills them and like in a pretty
and it's not one of these things where
it's like oh 16 years later it usually
happens like pretty soon after you sit
in it that's like the story
um so they i mean they said like locally
there's like a roofer who sat on it and
then like later in the day he went to
work on a roof and fell off and died uh
there was a woman who was like cleaning
the pub and she ran into it while she
was mobby she would sit in it
and uh she just kind of ran into it
while she was mopping the floor and then
like
later on she died from like a stroke or
a brain tumor or something
uh so it happened so often that the guy
that owned the pub was just kind of like
um okay well i'm gonna get this chair
out of here because it's like tempting
everybody so he moves it down to the
basement like thinking nobody will go to
the basement to sit in it but because it
had such a reputation
um you know people would still kind of
try to do it anyway because obviously
it's like a [ __ ] dare
uh so one day one day there's this
delivery man
and he was like you know delivering
something in the basement and he decided
he was going to sit in it an hour later
he was in a car crash and died
um and then after that like the guy that
owned the pub
uh was tried to give the chair away like
to a museum or something
and when they gave it to the museum the
museum was like well we don't want to
like take any chances so
they hung the chair like five feet off
the ground so nobody could sit at it
that's what people were talking about
earlier and there's pictures of it like
online where they've hung it like up on
their wall it's because they don't want
anybody sitting in it they don't want to
be responsible you know it'll be
ridiculous i mean you know just be on
the safe side i guess
um but you know
there's that kind of thing but yeah so
apparently as of 2014 i don't know about
nowadays but apparently the museum is
still there and the chair is still like
hanging five feet off the ground because
they don't want anybody sitting in it
because they'll [ __ ] die you know
what i mean
larry's making fun of me says i'm lit i
can't stop moving look
i'm [ __ ] loaded i didn't well
well you i would never [ __ ] deny that
yeah i'm loaded i'm drinking i'm gonna
stop moving i can't stop moving because
when the show's over i'm gonna go down
there and cook
honestly though i have to it's not even
drunk because you move around a lot when
you're sober too it's funny because when
one of our really old uh videos somebody
commented on it the other day like kind
of joking it's like the dude moves
around too much and i looked at the
video it was like from years ago yeah
and yeah you were just like
yeah and you were sober on that one that
was like do what i wanted that was
before we started tricking out just
trying to control the [ __ ] daddy
rolling ghost face says tom's like a
shark i do it already stops moving
get on my [ __ ] channel [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
look man i got [ __ ] i got to do once the
[ __ ] show's over i'm going to make
some taco meat okay you want yeah yeah i
got that got that ground meat down there
uh the ground meat is thawing
been thawing all day that really is
gonna be succulent sucking and juicy you
said succulents sucking succulent and
juicy ground beef i'm gonna make
something out of that
okay
you want taco meat out of that
um what are my other options i'm trying
to think
i mean if that's spaghetti
um i don't know that was good but i
don't know whatever you feel like okay
we'll see i'm not picky
dj maniac says please tell me this chair
of death still exists i need to take
people to sit in it um it might as far
as i know i don't know if that like that
museum is still open
um
but like i said they discourage people
from sitting in it it's like five feet
off the floor like i said i've seen
pictures of it
slasher fred said there's a horror
anthology film called trilogy of terror
yeah we've reviewed that yeah that
involves a woman who receives an african
doll
yeah that was sexy ass caramel sexy ass
kara brat with her [ __ ] cross eyed cj
baby accent sexy ass character
that's what we call her it must not be a
regular listener because like whenever
karen black shows up i'm [ __ ]
i [ __ ] never sexy ass karen black
and there there's there's a story behind
that that was my dad's favorite woman
my dad you're my favorite woman yeah
yeah my dad thought the [ __ ] karen
black was just the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] like i said there is something
like really sexy about it yeah now that
i've gotten older i see what he's
talking about she she uh she was an
unusual beauty yeah she was she was sexy
man i love trilogy of terror she was in
all three of the stories like playing a
different character although my favorite
movie of hers was burnt offerings yeah
and i loved it was good too yeah
oh and she was also in like a creepy ass
tv movie called the strange possession
of mrs oliver yeah and that was good too
that used to be free on youtube i don't
know if it still is but i used to i
really like that movie
all right last night would have said
that sexy ass karen black i can't